[Music]
you made it weird with Pete Holmes
what's happening weirdos this is the
incredible Taryn Killam who was one of
my all-time favorite SNL cast members
and now he's one of my all-time favorite
you made it weird guests this is a did
we just become Best Friends episode and
I'm so glad you guys are here a couple
things to mention up top I'm currently
on the road if you want to see me go to
petehomes.com lots of new tour dates
this new hour is so fun thank you to all
the weirdos that have been coming out
petehomes.com for all the tour dates New
York uh what else Denver Salt Lake City
these are all coming up go to Pete homes
and more peterhomes.com you get it also
if you'd like to support the show why
not try a pizza pick we only do ads for
things I actually use and actually love
and I'm so excited to introduce a new
pizza Pig Pete's pick which is bird dogs
this episode is brought To Us by my new
favorite best looking best feeling
shorts I've ever owned bird dogs I'll
show them these are my bird dogs I was
just for those of you in the uh watching
the video I was just swimming I've never
been a big short Sky I don't like swim
trunks even though I love swimming but
bird dogs are literally here to change
all of that especially now that summer I
love liberating my legs and getting in
water as often as I can and now thanks
to my dogs the dogs I can do so feeling
totally comfortable and looking and
feeling really really good bird dogs
make you look good they have a stretch
khaki shorts that are designed to fit
Slimmer through the thigh and your leg
giving you a truly sculpted look
basically doing the same thing Lululemon
does but let's be honest it's a plus
that is not Lululemon and it looks way
better they're not stiff it's not
restricting cotton bird dogs have fixed
this issue by inventing Cloud knit
fabric that looks just like khaki but
stretches to get you a way Slimmer fit
without having to sacrifice movement and
bird dog uses anti-stink anti-sweat it's
sweat wicking fabric that keeps you cool
and dry all day long these trunks I'm
wearing right now not only fit great and
look great but they dry really quickly
and they look incredible in and out of
the water so go to birddogs.com weird
and you will get a free Yeti style
tumbler with your order that's
birddogs.com weird support the show get
some awesome shorts or some swim trunks
and get a free Yeti style tumbler you
won't want to take your bird dogs off we
promise you
it's also brought To Us by our friends
at Living Libations you guys know I'm
mindful of what I put in my body but
years ago I realized I wasn't being very
careful about what I put on my body
which of course these things end up in
your body I was buying shaving cream you
guys know neon blue shaving goo isn't
good for your body these are filled with
chemicals linked to disease and toxicity
levels never intended for humans and I
realize I want to eat food where I
recognize the ingredients and I want my
skin care to be the same enter living
Libations not only the best and deep
down most effective skin care Hair Care
Eye Care teeth and baby products I've
ever found I'm sweating because I just
got out of the pool but also the most
natural made exclusively with plants and
oils and extracts that not only will you
recognize but you'll be able to easily
pronounce now that it's summer having a
natural zinc based sunblock for Leela
our daughter is so important and so many
of them have done my research that claim
to be natural just are not but living
Libations love the sun sunblock not only
works great lasts long on your body and
last long in the bottle but also we can
feel great about putting it on ourselves
and on our daughter all summer long so
this is a great way to support the show
get something small get something big
whatever you want to replace something
in your medicine cabinet Something in
Your Hair Care skin face body eyes teeth
even babies living Libations has a
premium natural and wonderful product to
replace the random chemical nightmare
they sell at 7-Eleven 15 off go to
livinglibations.com weird 15 off and
show your support of the show that's
livinglibations.com weird alright
everybody enjoy tear and kill them it's
so fun get into it yeah yeah be close be
close be close be close
oh
shoe friends press them press them to me
look at this
nice big feet Good Feet
big feet do you remember Never Ending
Story The Rock Eater of course strong
yeah did you say big feet too no but he
should have I tried to re-watch the
never-ending story
which by the way what a time to be alive
to be a stand-up comedian when the movie
the never-ending story came out
everybody just got a bit yo sure it was
over after two hours oh yeah it was
right there what are you talking about
yeah yeah also yeah yeah exactly a liar
yeah 90 minute run time false but I mean
there was a time that that was a fresh
and hot and exciting take yeah sure yeah
I I I'm yeah when it came out um yeah no
it should what do you think it should
have been still going because it's never
ending right but I tried to rewatch it
in that rock month it opens in like a in
a valley like a dark Valley I don't know
that I remember it well enough I
remember the kid and being like where is
he he's in an attic isn't the school in
an attic with skeletons when he's
reading the book yeah he's in a lot a
bookstore
the bookstore I remember the bullies and
he avoids the bullies or not at first at
first the bullies get him isn't it funny
that have you ever thought about this I
was just thinking about this the other
day that like
the movie's coming out now we're
actually are actually based on the
childhood of the people writing them
yeah so when we saw the bullies in uh
the never-ending story which came out in
the 80s yeah it's actually based on the
bullies the late 50s early 60s exactly
yeah yeah and that's why I remember
being like this isn't in line with the
bullying that I experienced it's not
like baseball cards stuck in the spoke
of the bike chasing me throwing rocks
and stuff it was more psychological it
was a lot more like it was who's
watching what can I get away with yes it
was and then posturing like there was a
guy who would find out what girl had a
crush on and then ask her out that's
80s that's 80s bullying folks that's
what
that's why that's why I like Iron Man
and Captain America are dealing with
that kind of stuff now
it's almost never right on the money
yeah like because you and I are now
writing things and we're basing it on
80s bullying exactly but people in 2023
are like that's not what bullying is
like now it's like a comment on my
Instagram post or whatever yeah yeah
Matt Morano called you the f word and I
don't mean [__] yes no I know I know
which one you mean I I love saying [__]
I hate saying the other one same unless
it's for Pure shock I'm just kidding I'm
just like unless it's just this is
interesting I was told a story Friday
night that basically the punch line or
the internet is that word yeah and it
still got under my skin and it was it
was not like they're telling it as a
joke it was the retelling of a very
famous celebrity encounter tell me the
story you don't it's not mine I'm
appropriating the story
when you say the word point to me and
I'll make the sound of a bike horn this
is great okay this is great
great everything looks like good
political Advocates good political
Advocate uh Great Hulk Great Hulk did a
role that no one else could do sorry Ed
oh damn sorry
what's that Eric Bana Eric Bana couldn't
do it okay I like the Eric Bana one a
lot I like that Ang Lee one I uh when I
say they couldn't do it oh
I'm holding space for you
and I felt that that's why I was so
delighted you're such an active listener
I'm already being healed of my 80s
bullying because this is good good yes I
want to step up my game so you feel how
good I feel because you just did you
anticipated a feeling it's so beautiful
they should study that I appreciate
Communications courses all I was saying
was Norton Banna all those guys didn't
have the tech the technology wasn't
there Ruffalo is the best Hulk but the
technology was the best to make the Hulk
not a joke yeah when Ed Norton turned
into a CGI nightmare yeah I mean that's
not his fault that's the thing I don't
know that I fully agree I think if you
go back and look at
keep telling me keep telling me it does
look better than I remember I thought
that Ang Lee was the first to capture
the the the eyes of the emotion and like
yeah angling it's and it's is it Nick
Nolte is the dad and that's like a weird
storyline but that's Hulk leaping
through the desert swinging tanks by the
thing like that's fun that's a Hulk
where you go like oh yeah he's dangerous
and he can do anything I want to watch
that now I didn't find it the Hulk dogs
was like a big criticism but I like the
emotion oh there were Hulk dogs in it
okay yeah yeah Hulk dog sounds like yeah
you know what I'm wary of single
sentences that explain why everything
sucks
look out for that that's that's Hulk
three Hulk Dogs come out in Hulk three
not Hulk okay Hulk is the one I should
watch that's what that one is right
angling Hulk Hulk Angley I like it
the first two unit that to my memory of
using comic panels in its visuals like
real it was a real love letter to the
source material and a real cinematic
heightening okay I thought okay I I am
fine to be wrong to the masses but well
speaking of that okay I'm gonna be
vulnerable but I'm okay yeah uh meaning
I'm comfortable in my vulnerability here
yes I just did something
that is something that comedians do and
do to good effect meaning it makes
people laugh and it's wonderful but I
also am embarrassed because when I said
that
I don't really remember if it looked
good or not I was just sort of going off
of uh I see that's okay I know that
thing cling yeah right yeah and in my
defense I'm just trying to get the yeah
yeah ball rolling hey it looked like
[__] right
no this doesn't work with that it
doesn't work
oh what a terrible thing we've given the
world
what does that mean yeah
but but I grew up in Boston in the 80s
and I feel like I can't say if it was
just that area but it was certainly that
area yeah there's a lot of like that
sucks without any ability to uh yeah and
I'm embarrassed that a little bit you
shouldn't be because I know I know
exactly what you're saying but I do I
mean we don't know each other well no
we've met in person only once before do
you remember do you remember where great
you know why because we love that stuff
so much we love that stuff but you know
what I remember Camille and Emily yes
Camille and Emily yeah what
that's what I remember I thought that I
was trying to guess the right why but I
didn't oh I remember uh that you did
Mulaney for me oh and I still
um
uh everybody says this but it was at a
time before everybody was doing Melanie
or it was less popular to do Mulaney
sure I knew Melanie specifically was
um
yeah that's funny that's what I remember
yeah yeah you just took me I remember
where we were standing because I love
Impressions so much they're like little
events yeah yeah that like that is what
I remember I remember being very happy
that day yeah and walking around and
seeing like this place yeah yeah it was
like when the Affleck bat suit was
coming out yes you're right I do
remember and I I liked it tell me think
of it see Boston Pete wants to be like
and it looks stupid yeah yeah no
actually it looks stitching like okay
cool and Affleck who better to play
Bruce Wayne you know what I mean I like
him as b-man too
that's just for me no you know no
that's just for me but billionaire
playboy different girl they I'm like
this guy knows that lifestyle this is
gonna be cool interesting and then and
then Bruce was a little more Sullen than
I want like like I like well I feel like
that's back tattoo F like I'm not sure
you're talking to an Affleck Aficionado
okay great I love Affleck awesome I know
yeah but actually it's very in Vogue a
lot of people I know in Boston like to
tease okay so when I say it's back
tattoo Affleck yeah I just mean it he is
a little uh despondent okay he has a
weight to him you ever talk here by the
way we don't have to talk about this
much longer but I think that's what
you're picking up in his in his Wane and
let me show all my cards when I say I
like his Batman what do I mean I just
like the way he looked in the suit he's
like sure his shoulders are incredibly
broad yes
he's bulky he's bulky Batman but what do
I like about Bales Batman
go ahead not much
like a turning head a turning head was
like the cell of that like Batman Begins
is just all Nolan of just like he's in
the shadows he's scary he can rip a gut
like yeah it was the first time that it
wasn't a cartoon where yeah suddenly a
guy goes up right like that's right and
I should say I should this is what the
whole Power Plus or whatever is going to
be I can't wait
I can't wait I'm such a hardcore Keaton
Batman like like you will not get a flaw
out of me from that whole thing and in
him being back in the Flash and the suit
I'm like yeah no the suit's never been
better than that but why except for the
complete inability to turn his head I
don't mind that I don't mind that fun
fact you know that you know what I mean
I don't mind I was just gonna say oh
funny yeah yeah we're about the same age
because when Batman came out I saw it 12
times in the theaters at a time when
seeing a movie in the theater was like
insane to go twice
you've never seen it yeah yeah the only
reason you see a movie is to like brag
that you've seen it totally I have 1250
or whatever it is yeah and I I had the
book there was a book that came out so
many things I had so many things I had
yeah I had I put a yellow sticky Post-it
at the video store on the cardboard
cutout of the Batman when the VHS tape
was coming and I had that for a few
years
VHS is coming up honored a sticky posted
this is mine yeah
wait for your network there no no I just
said
I'm eight or nine years old when it
comes out on VHS and you put a sticky
posted on it and you said I want yes
yeah what's to stop me from removing
that and putting my sticky posted I mean
we gotta reach out to Bear City video
because
they're in Big Bear in Big Bear I love
that you I would I'm seeing a log cabin
video store and I'm seeing and honoring
of the Post-it system the honoring of
the Post-it was great and a soft sir
like a like a frozen yogurt with with
Butterfinger crumbles on top you know
what I mean so 90s was sucking our DS
with that [__] with crunchy candy and
soft serve ice cream I remember the
first time I had that I also my my
ex-wife is from Maine okay and I
remember she had like a very big
bear-esque uh video store in her town is
there anything better that the warm like
what's that word the Norwegian word for
when you create warmth it doesn't matter
okay it's like an art do you know it
it doesn't matter
Hunger Games
[Music]
that Norwegian culture of everybody gets
to hang out with you once in their life
because that is just so fun that was
just so good what a treat you are anyway
the the snow did somehow every video
store whenever you went in whatever the
weather is outside it's now you're now
snowed in that video story it's like
it's quiet and Pa even a blockbuster
meaning even the corporate you're
talking about you're talking the process
of like you got in the car you got there
you scrape the thing and then you do the
this outside and yeah and then you're in
and now you're sitting they're playing
speed and on Thursday behind the counter
and you haven't seen it yeah
and that's what you want to get out
what's your favorite film festival guys
it was fans man
by the way just watch John Wick four
okay they now know that his let's I'm
gonna try it uh the John Wick yeah okay
you know what I'm talking about I sure
do yeah yeah
yeah that there's a little boy that gave
me that was an event
[Laughter]
yeah
I it does have a bounce I hear good
stuff I hear good stuff about four I had
to tap out after three I've reached the
age where I'm like it's over
guns I can't do it I will say oh no I'm
agreeing with you yeah when they're
picking an assault rifle that is like
ripped from the headline yeah I'm with
you I understand and I and I like want
to put my hypocrisy out there because
there is no
I can separate movie scene that revs me
up more than in Commando when he breaks
into that gun store and then opens a
secret wall yeah and he's grabbing all
the things I'm like like I was I was
making guns out of wood like yeah yeah
it's just where we are in history and
where I more specifically where I am in
my life in John Wick 3 he's like pulling
heads to the side to get it in there and
I'm just like uh no oh you didn't like
it I can't it makes me so sad I because
of the implications of world yeah of
world implications of world is
implications
welcome to implications of
we'll see on a pan in Japan
yeah it's so much more beautiful in
Japanese
it's one symbol it's one symbol it's
perfect it literally like it'll make you
cry if you don't know what it means I'm
with you but like uh like I get that and
I can still I'm not saying this out of
any defense I'm saying it out it's an
interesting subject why can I be so
against uh guns and and gun violence and
all that sort of stuff yeah when I can
enjoy that and I'm like the this is the
language of of our unconscious like sure
your dreams tapping into the Primal side
of things when you said it yourself I
forget where I saw this but
um
I don't know I was watching something
just about raising boys we both have
daughters I have a daughter and you have
two girls and by the way Leela's Fierce
and loves to fight and wrestle so like I
understand
broad Strokes gender normative
conversation alert yes but a lot of boys
even if their their parents are like
we've never let them watch a single
frame of Television you give them a long
stick they start killing you with it yes
and and by the way I don't think that's
that far from you give me sauerkraut I
start eating it because I'm from
Lithuania you know there's like a
genetic things going far away from it
it's pretty far until you taste how
spicy this Crown is it's like a rifle so
when I watch that I can it's another art
the art and the artists are separating
the art and the implications of violence
yeah yeah kind of yeah sort of way I
guess I hear I hear you like like Kill
Bill again yeah they're like it's so
Fantastical there's something about it
was specific to John Wick where they're
like we've done our research on guns and
animals I know I know what you mean it's
that thing and the way he reloads
but it's just like the um yeah I don't
know what it is I I've also entered I've
entered into and this is like within the
last two weeks I was like oh no
um I've entered into my like
studying and being overwhelmed by World
War II phase of my life how old are you
41 right on track
the lives the and why and I'm I'm just
like and every old man that I was like
oh you're reading a book about World War
II REM yeah yeah I'll have to go at
names
um I'm sorry Mr Mr Cavalieri where'd you
get that book
that leather-bound book yes and you read
it like The Neverending Story
it is I mean that was the number I know
what you mean I I had a sketch idea
where I wanted but I don't know why I
don't do it meaning I'll say it I don't
even care if someone else does it but it
was um uh henchman backstory henchman
obituary okay so you take a scene from
John Wick yeah and every time he shoots
somebody it freezes great uh plays I
will remember you so fun but the what
would actually make it funny is you have
to get very specific you'd be like Taryn
killum was like he shoots you was raised
in Big Bear California and had a deep
deep love saucer first yeah
sister with crunchy candy and the first
Batman he could put a Post-It on a
cardboard cut out of Batman you know
what I mean and then it resumes and he
shoots another one yes that so I'll say
that that's like my attempt at
reconciling how precious is it's so
silly and how evil doesn't exist mental
illness exists right unmet needs like
like they're like nobody's a henchman
right nobody's a henchman like totally
the movie could have been about that guy
I joined this great new outfit and they
told me to go into the into the
concierge yeah yeah shoot this bad guy
sure he shot me yeah yeah so fast but
also out the other side of my face when
I'm feeling this is in defense of those
things uh that are you know whatever
very black and white when I'm dealing
with issues and they might even be like
deep psychological or even spiritual
issues where I'm afraid sometimes
watching somebody who's just facing
fears you know what I mean like John
Wick is just not afraid yeah and he does
it yeah he's tired yes and he keeps
falling and he keeps getting broken
Ethan Hunt I think the mission possible
move movies are about the insatiable
zest of life like Ethan Hunt is life
life is an impossible mission but he
won't stop yes even though they keep
saying it ends you're gonna die I'm
gonna die you're gonna die it's
impossible yes you keep going get on the
motorcycle get the knife cut the thing
go in your boys are underneath in the
boat and we love watching that because
life is so [__] heavy and so
frightening sometimes you just want to
see something reduced to the most bit
not even primary colors just black and
white good and bad dead and alive
banging banging dead I feel like yeah
but I feel like this is like
transitioned into action movies in
general and that's not me like a mission
impossible I'll do yeah because mission
impossible for me is is so set piece
focused and almost like really like Rube
Goldberg puzzly like this must have
happened here heisty do this yes the the
the wow is the motorcycle in the
mountain yes not the 40 guys shot in the
neck I agree so it's very John Wick
specific I we is it possible I might
need to see it you can also watch man on
wire like there's certain docs that make
me go like don't be afraid that's what
it is it's love and fear right yes and
there's certain art certain art that
makes me more afraid yes I like I love
The Sopranos but I tried to re-watch it
during the lockdown and I was like this
is making me more afraid yeah I'm not I
I wouldn't say a bad thing about it
other than yeah it makes me a little
more distrustful of my neighbor yes John
Wicked is so cartoonish that it doesn't
make me go like oh I'm going to see
Taryn today I hope he's not dangerous
but The Sopranos might it might make me
be like what if he's unstable yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
um but but that's interesting I'm trying
I'm like in I'm going like what are the
movies that like make you less afraid
yeah and afraid I don't know I like I
don't know that the absence of fear is
possible because there's you know I'm
sure it was in Mission Impossible or
John Wick is like yeah you know courage
isn't not being afraid it's being afraid
and doing it anymore yeah exactly
um but just in terms of like low and
like go like no it's okay you know yeah
and you said man on a wire and that I
was like now yeah I totally that
resonates that understands and king of
Kong Fistful of quarters does it for me
can you hit it
sorry
[Laughter]
to kick it I asked me how many times
Taryn um you've seen it yeah Taryn I'm
here I'm listening
I could I can't tell you how many times
I've seen it because I'd be deeply
embarrassed oh it's I have an unnatural
I'll be the first to admit yes almost
compulsive obsession with king of Khan
Fistful of quarters yeah and I'll even
watch some of the offshoots you ever see
some of the copycat docs no no tell me
though because I obsessive it's a little
bit of a waste of your time it's my
favorite documentary for sure the best
documentary yeah and I think I saw it
with Kumail and Emily so we're back into
our little uh pool yeah I'm obsessed
with it but that one will show you that
it's not just the topic but fun spot in
general arcade 80s cabinet arcade games
arcade yeah that was just my safe yeah
what was your number one cabinet game
Street Fighter two okay had to be okay
close second I might say the Ninja
Turtles game yeah uh-oh that stepped
gonna kill him yep yeah yeah stepped in
a kill him we're coming April
yeah yeah yeah
you got to get those blasted Turtles oh
crane he was up I mean they always had a
burp all right
all right so good we this is a joke have
you ever had Rob Paulson on here no who
I wanted that rob Paul says the voice of
Raphael in the original Ninja Turtles
cartoon he's also the voice of Pinky
from Pinky and the Brain oh he's just
curious he's everybody but I mean he's
wrath and like raf's sardonic-ness like
every morning before school yes is a big
piece of this puzzle yeah he's cool but
really yeah yeah yeah give him a break
[Music]
does anybody else find this very
convenient it was always that you know
what I mean it was always fourth wall
breaking at the end like
we gotta get April and then like Cam
Clark doing Leo is like come on you guys
Master Splinter says
Donny's my least one but then like it's
always rough going like so we're going
into the big scary tunnel
anybody else think this is a bad idea
he's comedy he's comedy doing it but
he's the only like that's how I feel you
just made me realize I think I am wrath
okay I wanted to think I was Leo oh
great oh good for you I mean that's
admirable yeah I'm a rap striving Leo
yeah yeah yeah I'm striving Leo but I am
around okay but I'd rather be raft now I
long for Raph I I'm probably pretty
hardcore Raph Michelangelo cartoon yeah
film wise I'm not Raph wait in the film
how does he change film's like I lost a
sigh then it is gone but I could get it
back I can get it back Jose Canseco man
tell me you didn't pay money for this
can I tell you
can we talk about the socioeconomic
implications of voice acting in
children's cartoons prefer not to okay
no no please oh you know I changed my
mind we're gonna go back to ninja
turtles because I'm dead but I started
with an F Word by the way oh no I got
Ruffalo I got Ruffalo on the brain I
know ruffalo's found
ation
everyone listening watching we'll get to
Ruffalo but I was gonna say
okay
um my daughter watches a show called
Spidey and His Amazing Friends love it
do you watch it oh yeah yeah then get
that Spider-Man it's based off
Spider-Man and His Amazing Friends which
is also great yeah yeah if you I like it
a lot my daughter and I call that old
Spider-Man fun it's also the original
the 70s one fire star yeah and Iceman
yeah deeply sexually charged have you
noticed sure that [__] because it's
being written by guys who grew up in the
Pressed in the 50s you my sir have
served me a meal the likes of which I
never wish to finish
like I'm already planning on tipping 300
like I'm I'm whispering about I don't
care what the bill is I'm tipping this
man 300 okay
what is going on let me ask you this is
a real dream come true for me I don't I
don't know any other dads that know this
show and also think about voices and
comedy yeah tell me about rhino rhino
yeah do Rhino's voice
no but he's gonna stop me
hey yeah let me ask you about it okay
sure uh where is he socioeconomically
oh interesting uh did he did he do well
in school probably not yeah probably not
yeah I know I'm putting you on the spot
that's okay I'm gonna say I'll be the
face of this that voice and that
character who can't stop charging you
can't stop it yeah you can't stop me
Spidey yes does he have two parents you
know what I mean hey now let's talk
about uh I like a lot of things about
you but your care is like
Paramount what do you mean you care
about every you care so much oh I think
a lot I suppose you're very analytical
you really like I gotta figure this out
but why is that a bad guy he's the bad
yeah okay I do care yeah he's the bad
guy so Spidey talks like he goes to a
pretty good Montessori school I see
doesn't he okay okay he's like well my
new web fluid he talks like the guys
yeah yeah he's sweet he's kind he's
considerate these are all virtues that
we want I understand but why does the
bad guy who can't stop running right
have a Brooklyn accent yeah because he's
probably not he's probably from an
underfunded public school system this is
the difference between you and I like
your care is like who is this person how
are they being represented where do
where do we go from was it and I'm like
well he was like Russian in the comic
foreign
you know what I mean so we've gotten
better yeah you've gotten better I'm not
I'm not you mean we were always putting
our shadow into the villains and the
shadow used to be dirty Iron Curtain I
think more Spidey and His Amazing
Friends is you're going from uh six
seven hundred years six Decades of Canon
yeah so I think you're there you're
always citing a source I don't know that
they're starting from scratch but but
now from very little I know about like
children's animation at that age too a
lot of thought does go into like the
curriculum of the episode that's right
um but I feel like this is a blind State
I think it's a blind spot I'm not even
saying it shouldn't be but if Rhino just
can't stop charging and he has a British
accent sure I just can't stop charging
right maybe you could be evil British
okay let's talk about goblin Green
Goblin okay
I get like weird this is almost
inappropriate to say but he doesn't seem
like he has a girlfriend I'll say that
okay he seems kind of like a queen
they're young for girls though oh but I
see it just yeah I think it's like a gay
stereotype I think he's it's almost like
my weather machine and then let me ask
you about Doc Ock on that show does she
have a boyfriend she seems like a
lesbian scientist okay maybe I'm reading
way too much into this but there's
there's some
[Music]
ah by the way to be super clear nothing
wrong with being a reclusive green uh
potentially I'm
his name nothing wrong with me
there's nothing wrong with that we
actually have a guest tarp if you'd like
to be covered in the guest tarp while I
make this point I'm not saying any of
this is right I just think it's
interesting to ask ourselves why do the
three main characters talking sweet or
it's almost too touchy to say articulate
but you know what I mean yeah I like so
so my mind is in two trains of thought
there's two trains on two tracks right
now one is what is the inverse and you
gave an example like British British
Rhino is different like well spoken or
or or tough or like Spidey talk like
Rhino and was like we gotta stop that
guy from charging yeah yeah yeah
charging you don't like that no okay I
know it's not even that I don't like it
but aren't we saying like this kid is
being raised by his television and the
other train is is is
um circumstantial process right so you
need vocal distinction
can't sound like Rhino or you do and it
might be too scary if he's just like I
can't stop charging that would be too
frightening ooh intense so it's gotta be
kind of like I'm cleaning who's somebody
that's already doing voices that can do
something different from what they do
who's doing every Hood limit in Ninja
Turtles was also like hey Shredder let's
go it was always that voice yeah oh yeah
that's Bebop am I right uh yeah it was a
rock steady
Public Schools sure
uh they're not and again here's the
danger zone Pete
can a kid that goes to a private school
not talk like that
yeah I I know what you're saying and I
appreciate that yeah because I'm also
speaking in real time yeah and I
understand that it's a risky subject
it's a difficult it's an important one
honestly but I think it's important but
I hear what you're saying I hear that's
why I can't say this enough I can't be
wrong but that that's actually the jump
you just made is if we were at a a hoity
toity uh uh Montessori private school
yes and a kid was like yo teach these
numbers
uh-huh wouldn't you be like does this
school work and is that right maybe
that's not right but is it how human
beings work you know they are they are
are we irrational judgment monsters I
wonder now about the responsibility
I wonder now about the responsibility of
of of
Spidey and His Amazing Friends
uh with regards to that and I think that
the answer is some because this isn't
just a Spider-Man Adventure but
Spider-Man does does exist in archetypes
it's all about archetypes yeah it's all
about Shadow light uh greed uh
selflessness yes even Goblin is Greed
for sure exactly but so it's about
exploring those archetypes honoring the
library of source material that has come
before Spidey the visual of of rhinos
the big kitties around head and and it
doesn't
that's part of it too but that's the
character I know yeah yeah
he's slow I'm probably a guy that you
know you you get when you need to move
something heavy but yeah yeah yeah you
know yeah you get the rest of the Riff
I'm not even comfortable doing it but
that is what he's visually representing
like I would I would say that that the
character design of rhino looking like
that is going inside hey come on you
guys you know like what oh I'm so
frustrated right now this is Spider-Man
I just gotta get me you'd be like I
don't he's blunt he's blood yeah yeah so
you're saying extra I was just thinking
about this today that like you know when
somebody maybe they get a divorce but a
good divorce or or somebody stops
drinking or whatever their outsides does
sometimes not always but sometimes the
outside is becomes a manifestation of
your inside okay certainly in the world
of cartoons that is true yes so Rhino is
blockheaded and and
um he's not elegant no he doesn't slide
through a china shop he knocks
everything down which is rude it's
inconsiderate yes right so that's why he
looks the way he does this is my dream
just wanted to talk about this with
somebody yeah I do have slight regrets
saying that Doc Ock looks like a lesbian
I no lesbians don't have a look per se
but I and and what is the other side of
it I'm just saying yeah Spidey and his
team are into science in a reasonable
way but she's like the I've taken
science too far it's become my God I'm a
Godless modern yes I'm circling back to
you caring you want to care about each
individual and I think the function of
Mythology and storytelling in general is
to do and don't is the Goofus and
gallant and you have to have the wrong
way to do it to show the right way to do
it right and if everybody's doing it the
right way we live in a Utopia and
there's no Spidey and his amazing
friends because we're all outside
building making beautiful already loving
each other yes I love that and I'm
calling [__] on myself because what
how else could we do Doc Ock she has to
be off the rails to a certain extent she
has to be she seems isolated it's not
even her fault it's really the tentacles
and the way that they're affecting her
brain I know and she only has four
because her four limbs
we've given this some thought playing
with the toy with my daughter like
shouldn't she have eight
foreign
I do think there's a there's I mean
I think it actually does tie back to
John Wick we're like using
uh shadowy colors uh-huh and and I'm I'm
with you I do think you could go to a
Montessori school and have a kid talk in
a deep Brooklyn accent yeah I just think
because being Children of the 80s I
think there's a henchman voice and that
henchman voice is tied to a person in
the same way that when you have a when
Legolas talks in a British accent
there's an implication there and I'm
also going to call [__] on this
whole subject that you have to make some
choices at some point Orcs also talk
kind of like okay they're also talking
like they don't read books you see what
I'm saying all types of Tolkien is like
Troublesome so Troublesome yeah I think
I think
to the first two Hobbits and like I love
the hobbits I I grew up reading that
book over it like annually the scary
cartoon
um I love the scary times looks like a
bad Acid trip it's so where there's a
whip
there is a way you just brought me back
today
I like it and I don't like how overly
okay this is exciting because can you
call up what Gandalf sounds like in
those cartoons tell me I can't he well I
would guess I'll do a guess
so not he talks very much like this
Bilbo you must go on this adventure he's
very much
it's Gandalf I know it sounds like
yeah it's very much here come the Five
Armies they're not like it's it's very
much not
because it's not McKellen I feel like
now everybody hears right a wizard is
McKellen right yeah yeah and we can talk
about the implications of that voice
dude the quiver is age is wisdom is like
this is just a selfish like tell me do
you have a Dumbledore opinion on the
recasting of that because I have a
strong one I don't even remember oh
Richard Harris versus Michael Gambon
because Michael gamble died uh Richard
Harris died scratch that reverse it okay
Richard Harris Richards died
sure
so he was recast I can't picture it for
some reason Harry Potter never got its
teeth in me on the same way that others
did okay yeah it's very deep in our
household okay and what's your take
because people are going to want to know
uh Richard Harris
gentle aged very subtle but very twinkly
very playful like yes really kind of
nailed well I just thought it was going
into Hogwarts I love it Marco Grand bone
is very angry and very everything's on
the surface Harry there are always foul
things about us how and you're just like
no wow no no like when it needs to be
all twinkle and it it it it needs to be
the veneer of I have it all together and
the most important things are jelly bean
flavors guys yes I can break a mountain
with my magic yes but I want to play a
game of you know of a pickup sticks or
whatever right right right right well
that's an archetype it's it is of like
and the beauty of the seven books is and
obviously there's trouble everywhere you
step Pete well this is what I'm saying
is if you separated about this world in
symbols from this world yeah you're
gonna be making mistakes your dreams are
inappropriate yes I agree music is
inappropriate song like yes stories are
inappropriate like no matter how hard we
try here's how the comparison will make
no matter what you eat you [__]
something up you [__] something up an
ecosystem A Bug's Life an Amoeba's life
right someone else's food that would
have been a [__] Fox's lunch you're
eating it yes so even if it's not an
animal there's no way to take a breath a
step anything in this world without and
why would it be different in the art
that we create I'm not saying it's a
pass yeah I'm just saying there's a
certain wisdom in going like I know it's
not perfect yeah like when I tell my
daughter story it might not be as
nuanced as it needs to be in regards to
the Goblins yeah and that and you're
we're going into that jungian space
where it's like totally yes when we're
trying to tell stories about an
imperfect World they will be in fact
imperfect and if they were perfect no
story nothing happens keep going I like
it I mean I'm just taking in that wave
because yeah actually cancel Spidey and
his friends not the 70s one because
that's early morning bonus that's early
morning that'll cancel itself and it'll
renew itself because that show is
smoking a cigarette nice man yeah that
show is nice man freeze him Fire Starter
nice job babe she is naked yeah and her
boobs sorry I don't mean to be but they
have like that 70s swoop yes they look
like ski slopes which implies nipple
which implies boner totally oh
doesn't destroy something else is mad
the scientists
are right the swoop is a nipple zero has
no value
[Music]
he apologize for all the mistakes
but and yet here we are okay
um you were talking about Dumbledore oh
yeah yeah just gambling on this two
frazzles and there's no like mystery and
then part of that journey is that
Dumbledore seems infallible and then you
buy book Seven you're like oh he's human
like everybody else he's made he's made
life-changing mistakes he said tragedies
so it's that and but you have to kind of
protect that and then show the
vulnerability and Gambon for me for my
money for my preference was just very
angry yeah I was just like I don't buy
it I understand yeah and I was also
thinking I was kind of replaying some of
the things we've said and you know you
know what's interesting about the
conversation we're having is I'm not
saying these are judgments I'm making
this as much as I'm taking on the hat
that I inherited in the 80s putting it
on and saying what does that hat tell me
about what I'm watching let's judge it
through that lens I love that even
though I feel like I can dissociate from
that lens okay I still remember it
that's where you get things like
Brooklyn accent means yeah I didn't go
to a great school necessarily and
um do it again huh that's funny that's
yeah yeah
um murder huh
Maybe
3 A.M meeting that's very good yeah
that's what what it did for me was yeah
I've been I love it yeah
um
that's what the writers on my old talk
show said was the impression of me when
I hate a joke is I'd go I love it uh but
it was just because you're just thinking
about it yeah
Rings you just you just rewatch The Two
Hobbits we did the two Hobbits and
they're Troublesome because what the
dwarves or something I think that there
is a uh I think that there's a very it
has been made by many people correlation
to dwarves being uh Semitic people right
also Harry Potter too the bank the
goblin the guy you say the Goblins in
that one and yeah you know they goblins
was a little too you think they went to
I think any time
that is people's and audiences direct
correlation right and then okay
and it's but they're like we'll give you
a loan like this is a little exactly
anybody it is anybody it is anybody it
is anybody yeah is is anybody but but to
your point Legolas like elves a British
High you know teacher also and the
royalty they're also celebrities Jared
Leto they're so clean and they're clean
do you know
through you said it basically like Peter
O'Toole from uh Lawrence of Arabia it's
clean what do you like about the desert
it's clean
terrifying have you seen that movie no
should I no
can I tell you for the Cinematic the
shots are wide they shot the desert
forces
we finally did it Kobe and I did it
during the pandemic we're like Lawrence
of Arabia like Robert says it's like his
favorite we have to watch it it's crazy
yeah Spielberg was eating like Reese's
Pieces but in the 70s that had like
cocaine yeah yeah he was having a
difference he wanted to eat M M's but
Eminem said no
riff of the century I got it okay I got
every part of it and everyone else did
okay there are people that don't even
know that story about E.T that knew in
their bones what you were saying thank
you thank you well done okay so goblins
and anti-Semitism they just just oh and
and the just to the point I think of
like socioeconomics assigned to an
entire race not a character an entire
race yes Tolkien did seem to
oversimplify and I think this isn't my
take on it but I have heard and it's
easy to observe certain correlations to
different race factions within that
world yeah right
yep yep yep what do we do because these
are some of the great I think that it's
about the Bible sometimes the Bible was
like
you know 2 000 years ago you watch uh I
watched what was it the last duel did
you watch the last duel yes I really
liked it you are an Affleck fan I do
love it and that's that's him skiing he
sometimes he surf sometimes he skis
he's skiing you know where else he's
skiing he's having fun while hunting he
he came back notes of Chucky so good in
the last tool but the last tool is the
Dark Ages uh or it's about to be the
dark it's about to be the dark yeah it
seems pretty dark and that was like
a long time after the Bible people are
like brushing their teeth with the rats
we're looking at four thirteen fourteen
hundreds that's what I'm saying yeah so
it's like thank you for that I couldn't
I found it for the life of me no I don't
know but that's exactly so I do know
that the witch trials are 1690s sure
right so that's
1690 years after Christ and that was
when we were like put a leech on your
dick on the full moon like we were full
of [__] [__] we didn't know goddamn
anything so when people have a problem
with the Bible I'm like first of all the
Old Testament and I'm like that's five
1000 years yeah yeah yeah it's amazing
that anything is usable and do you
subscribe to the variations of it that
it's being Rewritten and only to your
point of Storytelling Stories being told
in a flawed world will end up being
flawed and that there have been there
are many owners of the Bible of being
the tellers of that story you mean like
changing it and yeah the Roman Church
rewriting different Scrolls being found
after a thousand and all these you know
of course the apostles themselves all
having different you know prove if we
weren't filming this prove what we said
in the house is something I always said
like we always forget that we live in
this nebulous conundrum yeah and but we
really please ourselves by being like
you had breakfast this morning and I
know it yes yes
when really all that's ever happened is
this just uh yes and that's even
questionable totally so the fact that
the Ten Commandments is a goddamn
Revelation it it just is I only bring
about that point a thousand years ago to
enhance your point of like yeah it's
like do you believe all or believe none
of it is like not fair no and not
realistic you want a fun fun one from my
Christian College day okay just a fun
little if you're ever at a cocktail
redundant but go ahead what Christian
College fun and Christian College
I thought you were hurt I got it you
didn't have to say fun man there was a
time when every College was Christian
isn't that weird Harvard is a Christian
College yeah it is or it was founded as
well anyway they just called it College
back then but they also brushed their
teeth with rats this is my point
um the part of the Lord's Prayer for
thine is the kingdom and the power and
the glory forever and ever amen which is
everybody's favorite it's the closer yes
uh was definitely added by a scribe
isn't that fun yeah so what I like about
that is it shouldn't it doesn't mean you
have to stop saying that at the end of
the prayer but to me it says invitation
to remember that it's all a mystery and
it's all the whole point of it is what
it does for you what it stirs inside of
you in this moment it's not about in
your brain being like I know Jesus said
this we wrote it down it made it 2 000
years all the way to me and now I'm
saying it and it's his magic words and
now I'm magic yeah [__] all that [__] or
if it's real or if it's that it's just
where it takes you in this moment what
else could be the point of anything
except what it does for you and I really
believe we all have two I was thinking
about the Looney Tunes the Angel and the
devil yes
I think that's one of the most true
things there is yeah and and what a gift
it was obviously Looney Tunes isn't the
first one to do it but we do have a
higher self a quiet small part of you
that knows everything like the Bob
Marley song everything's gonna be all
right yeah yeah you love things they're
like it's going to be all right yes and
then the devil which is our ego it's our
protector it's this thing is also kind
of going like actually there's a lot to
be scared of I'm not saying he's not
right in a certain sense but they both
coexist and everything whether Jesus
said it or not is either nudging you
towards love or towards fear at the end
how how would you Pete voice your angel
versus how would you in the animated
show okay Pete's Heavenly shoulders okay
howdy what is the voice of the Angel and
what is the voice of the devil here's my
devil then you're gonna do it okay great
yes yes yes obviously my devil is this
yes all right hello hello
I can't help but notice that your
neighbor is sunbathing topless
what do you say we get that letter and
go up on the roof with a little
jerkiness
and then I can't do them but my angel is
Jack my prayer
that's her private space
where does it end come on you know the
right thing to do
and why don't we just go make a peanut
butter and jelly sandwich yeah you are
reminding me
we're gonna get to yours and we're going
to get directions I was just noticing
like I like doing Trump because it's
just fun and somebody I noticed that
it's closing the nose oh you know like
you know as an impression is when you go
like wait yeah and there's it's like you
ever see a puppet like a good puppet
from The Henson people and the the back
of the
and the back of the face is all these
buttons like it has eyebrow articulation
yeah the different ring things that they
can pull I feel like an impressionist
finds that in their in this part of
their face oh and you go like oh Trump
isn't it's a great time it's actually
you close it up you close it up because
you gotta close it and then and then you
go oh I have another little piece of it
yeah and yeah I'm gonna tell you like
and you just noticed I heard my nerves
of coming here is knowing you to be a
very thoughtful very analytical person
and I am struggling with in my life
right now to open myself to more
analysis because I think for the first
half of my life I was like wait analyze
it you kill the joy you know and and I'm
only bringing that up because
specifically to Impressions I'm not you
don't think about it I don't think I
just go does it sound like that like I I
picture it in my head interesting and I
just replicate it well it's like a
muscle memory though yeah
it was closed in the notes yeah yeah
yeah yeah
right there hey hey there that's nice
that's nice yeah yeah yeah but it is
very Musical and yeah it's more it's
more does it sound right to my ear and
then picturing like I can kind of
picture the person in my head and he's
always his head's always up a little bit
well to the right way he's like hey I
don't think that's very nice personally
and if I and I wouldn't be a proper
young lad if I didn't ask you to leave
this place at once you know like that's
exactly it yeah yeah okay I got it and
I'm thinking about it you are okay yeah
no no but that actually can be a
handicap you know it can it can slow the
game down yeah I don't know I I think
yeah same I think the same of like well
but you got to look at your [__] too and
you gotta how are you gonna better if
you don't take notes but if you're
remembering things like sometimes I have
to write them down like you don't have
like it sounds like you don't like a
touchdown I suppose but sometimes I
forget the Touchstone like for me Pacino
some some
some sort of hey yeah yeah yeah how are
you right all right yeah and then
that sometimes needs to be written down
though like I need to write down like
you said the bounce for Keanu yeah
yeah
okay what's the voice of your devil oh
God the voice of my devil
um
the voice of my devil of the like is is
like um do you know who uh
um Patrick pages
it's such a nerdy theater thing he plays
Hades in uh yeah yeah
[Applause]
why do we build the wall my children my
children I think just that would be
that's the sound that's the voice the Mr
Grinch voice basically yeah yeah exactly
uh uh Thurston railvin what's his name
is that him yeah Ravenscroft thorough
Ravenscroft great name did he change it
out
I don't know now I'm no longer Sam e
wise yes exactly I'm no longer I'm
certain Ravenscroft they're all
Ravenscroft that's his name and he's
You're a mean one and he's also win the
ghost come out to socialize he's that
guy that's devil okay that's great I
feel like Angel
you can say it's like it's okay it can
be me it's gonna be Pete Holmes thank
you I was gonna say my wife
but I like of just like no I want to be
better I want to I want to do a
beautiful answer now I say that about
Val that's my wife all the time is like
it's like your partner should be the
little reminder
of your higher self yeah and and she's
with me all the time and and like to
really like analyze and go in on it like
she the way she moves through the world
like part of my biggest Attraction part
of my commitment to like I want to be
with you for life is that the way she
treats others the the her discipline her
these are all things I aspire to emulate
her yeah but then there's also like the
angel voice it's like you know you
should do this and you're like so
annoying I mean like there's that part
of it too interesting like yeah I know I
know
I know we'll get to it where do you
struggle I do laundry once a week okay
that's such a like cliche married I
don't know I pulled that reference but
no I thought well is that important we
have a hot tub that I was cleaning it
and I thought this morning I was like
men clean hot tubs yeah yeah yeah so
stupid big machine
I live the more I'm like just like Tim
Allen was right
I clean the hot tub yeah and like I
should make it extra water yeah men
cleaning the melon was right Tim Allen
was right
and Val it's just a classic head of
heart thing like she's just so hard and
she but she doesn't Val will go deep but
she just I'm wondering what your wife
has that you aspire to Bala just has
more of an embodied
less reactive like I get real another
way to put it is I'm just more in touch
with my anger more of my fire and she's
more of a water yeah peacemaking I think
that applies to us as well she's she's
like all others Comfort before mine
right isn't that annoying though
sometimes uh sometimes sometimes and for
you yeah I think so yeah and I'm like
I'll get comfortable I'll get
comfortable and I'll help anybody who
needs it you know what I mean yeah yeah
yeah yeah no I got my thing what's the
rules what is the plan what is the goal
great done got it okay who needs help is
she not super goal oriented I I know
we're talking about very much very much
so oh yeah yeah or she is or she isn't
she is goal oriented but it's like I
will get there but this person but on
the road to getting there this person
needs help that's the priority that's
interesting because I was just thinking
about I was just watching some great you
know how YouTube sounds like you're just
like bullshitting with some video but
then you watch some and you're like this
is better than Nova something that has
everything will have the best of it and
the worst of it yes yeah and this was a
good one I forget what it was or I would
give it a shout out but it was a video
and was talking about the Mythos
about of of uh of Maverick top gun
Maverick oh I have a whole theory on
that well we still have Ninja Turtles
and we still we we finished Lord of the
Rings though didn't we
um yeah comfortably question mark yeah
uh okay let's get into Maverick but they
were saying
and I really immediately agreed with
this that the Western mythology it's all
Mythos it's just a fancy way of saying
that the story we're all kind of living
under especially as men and whatever I
know women that that movie means a ton
to as well so people that are living
from a masculine Place yeah
um the story is you can do it believe in
yourself go for it don't be afraid do
what others will not and occasionally
accept help the last one is important
right it's a stake that's you and the
side dish is like two pieces of broccoli
but those pieces of broccoli are super
important because it's when the
helicopter with the double guns comes up
and someone comes in and saves you sure
by the way this is Batman this is every
story yeah that you and I were ever told
cut to me I sounded like Terence McKenna
not to me
the strange thing about psychedelics I
can't quite do it it was okay yeah I
like that
um Katie liked it all right Rock and
Katie cut to me in my life what am I
doing going for it obviously Katie's a
good example Katie helps I accept help
from Katie yes and Joe our YouTube guy
but for the most part I feel like I'm
out there I'm trying to book the guests
trying to make the show you know that's
that's me noticing our Mythos isn't a
group of hunters it's one it's Rambo
interesting he said Commando it's
Commander yeah yeah it's Predator yeah
you fight the monster and maybe at the
last second yeah uh Han Solo comes back
and and she's the guy at the right
moment right hit it wow yes oh that's it
yes yes period yes what's your thing
subscribe and like uh don't like I
actually guys if you're watching this on
YouTube subscribe but don't like it and
comment but then delete it it helps the
algorithm if you comment and then delete
it
um Maverick I saw it entertaining is all
get out it's a very silly movie
also doesn't work on the TV I don't know
if you tried to watch it yeah
this is the only
is at first I was like you know we we
will we will bend backwards and move
worlds to give Val back in there yeah
but Kelly McGinnis go [__] yourself
we're getting Jennifer oh
like this is McGinnis and this is
because she aged like a human being
she's
a person a human a person I'm saying
that in her defense I'm saying she but
Val as well
the masculine values or whatever
by that that's completely valid yeah
yeah they were like it doesn't matter he
can literally be ill maybe Kelly can
still talk yeah yeah exactly but touched
down is she I I don't want to Riff on
that it's too it's too it's sensitive
and it's and everybody deserves love and
recognition and I just think like in a
movie that is fueled by Nostalgia it is
like the lifeblood of that movie is
remember you know yeah
um that the Jennifer Connelly Thing by
Nostalgia unless it's not ripping hot
unless well this The Nostalgia is that
women are beautiful and they never well
but women are okay so Tom Cruise being
in I love T Cruz but he's being injected
with so many things that are keeping him
up there's a lot of fresh effects being
done oh yeah like because it's not his
fault that's not like Tom is out there
saying you need to make me look perfect
that's also the mythology he can't age
he can't be weak he can't deteriorate
totally and the women it's bees and
flowers man he needs to have a sharp
stinger and I know bees are girls are
they girls
but the flowers need to stay beautiful
and fertile it's like what we do we
don't know what to do with I'm not
calling them Crohn's but this idea that
women become Crohn's they dry up and
they're no longer so their whole point
was to be baby makers for yes powerful
chiseled men obviously is still at play
and and if you kind of look like you hit
menopause what are you doing in this
movie you need to think that they're
right there's a more interesting and
elegant and emotional way to tie in if
you're gonna tie it all the the past in
tie it all in but here's my theory
be happy have her be yeah what because
it's what ambition and drive and and and
going the fastest and doing the thing
that she said that's not for me and she
did something and it's lovely and soft
and that's equally as valid I don't know
right I hear you I'm not trying to
rewrite it but the Jennifer Connelly
thing just that was the thing that stuck
me a lot was like oh man you know
because
so here's my theory
Tom at first I was like watch the movie
as if Jennifer Connelly is a ghost
because she never really interacts with
anybody else she is the younger she's
this Phantom version of what he thinks
he deserves right like it's interesting
it's gotten better I've I've I've I've
pitched I've worked on I have spitball
I've re-written I've edited he does not
survive that initial test flight
the test flight and the thing where he's
gonna be he dies it fails and everything
you see after that is his fantasy of
what his life you should be you're
talking Birdman yes he dies on stage
wow he dies in that test flight you
can't push it to think he dies and then
it's he goes back to his old school
where his Nemesis is inferior is ailing
and like he needs to go and show him
love because he's now on the
unthreatened top dog his biggest flaw is
that he cares too much
this is and the girl and the the thing
and these boats he's on a boat he's
sailing he's like he's got another
motorcycle he's a motorcycle with no
helmet it's like who's allowing that
yeah
he's threatened by me he doesn't like me
because he doesn't get it like Ed Harris
is there he's threatened by me everybody
and my biggest problem and by the way
they need me for a mission where drones
don't work where it's in the country
and why don't Jones work
because they need me to fly it that's
why they need they need me in the canyon
just like Star Wars to fly it don't say
just like Star Wars but it is that's
Maverick's favorite movie
that's why this is happening to fly
through the canyon to drop the bomb
exactly like Star Wars
unnamed unnamed country with an unnamed
threat that America the the nation that
spends more on military defense by 10
times anybody else doesn't have the
right planes that can keep up
but they need Maverick it's all his you
mean the people in the movie paying one
tenth of what we spent have better
planes yes
this is too long for an Instagram clip
and that's the greatest regret of my
life
ow this whole thing deserves to be a
real yeah right wow yeah look we've
gotten deep but you've gotten for a guy
who doesn't like to think
this whole time I'm like self-analyzed
right right I'm just enjoying so much
the same but you go everywhere so okay
you're saying you don't like to
self-analyze but like they're without
going too much into it what you're
saying is so clearly the masculine uh
Western mythology I can do it they need
me yeah like and and they're I'm not
even [__] on it like purpose is so
and I get to write my biggest regret I
lost my best friend [__] freaking me
out man I lost my best friend how can I
make that right can I tell you okay so
I've been working with Matt McCarthy and
Oren Brimmer we did the Batman we do the
Batman videos together and and just like
any relationship that's spanned over a
decade we've had times never like bad
sour disgusting times but just kind of
times where we're less in touch and and
I would say this if Matt was here in
fact it's quite a lovely story Matt and
I sort of uh fell out of touch and we
were just kind of living in parallel
there was a moment where it just seemed
like we wouldn't be friends again
um and then we reconciled
Maverick and uh and Son yeah yeah
exactly and the the pleasure I get
literally falling asleep at night
uh having a tour I love having something
that I'm gonna do so that's purpose
that's a mission yes writing a wrong a
friend that slipped away and he gets it
too we're like two dudes in our 40s that
can make each other cry just going like
that life can be long enough that like
we're back together and things are good
and we're almost like different people
yeah and that's baked into this movie
like and I'm thinking about my dad he
would he loves being needed he would
love to like have the mistakes of the
past go like we understand by the way I
feel as I'm saying this not just my dad
isn't that what everybody kind of wants
I think so to feel special feel special
that's my shorthand is like everybody
wants to feel special and forgiven and
understood I guess that is all under the
umbrella of special I think so I think
so yeah yeah the forgiven and understood
good I think that people would Define
that different I don't know that that's
in everyone I hear you thanks I'm sure
there's many people who've lived their
lives not feeling
the need to be forgiven or or there's
many people who take pride and like
nobody gets me and that's what turns me
and that's what makes me feel special uh
you know it's a specialist I actually
think you're absolutely right for me the
way that my psyche is wired
Val has noticed whenever we hang out
with new people I will make
inappropriate jokes and I'm just looking
for someone that's safe yeah yeah
because if once we become friends those
kind of those pretty much go away yeah
but I'm just going like are you gonna be
weird yeah or can I say interesting some
of the things I've said to you today
bicycle horn what's that bicycle horn
yeah
what can I say
so you don't do self analysis I I'm
trying to I'm trying to I'm you know in
in my
the old they're all reflective 40s uh
just going just just in terms of because
yeah
um yeah
impressions are a great small example of
that like impressions are like I watched
the person I go like you know they sort
of sound like this and if it's not in
there like I was desperate to do a
Robert Downey Jr but I'm just it's not
within my vocal range I think you can do
it yes it's not it's just not hey right
guys we could do it ordering for burgers
it's just that clipped thing yeah like I
can hear but just the sound of tone but
I can't is that what you is that what do
you think all right I'm gonna you're
gonna come in here and well Dad he's got
that twine but yeah I can't can I can I
share something with you this I think
might be fun yeah Paul this is my Paul
Rudd oh it's not it's not vocally
correct okay but it's like okay
I've done this so many times on the show
I'm embarrassed it's two because he's
gonna do two uh meaning this is Paul
riffing which always makes the movie
because it's always so funny
over there having a water drinking up
drinking a drinking a liquid death
drinking a lick good right it's always
the second one he gets it on the second
yes
this guy's baseball hat
hide the bald spot yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
wow
that's really good oh my God gonna have
a taquito
what are you having some Mexican food
wow I'm gonna have a couple can I have a
couple taquitos yeah that's it yes
that's the closest well done well done
it's great it's just giving me the
specialness we were just talking so good
I saw it immediately I get excited you
know what made me reach out I've been
meaning to reach out for you for a long
time to you for a long time but Bobby
Moynihan mentioned the of Brad Pitt yeah
yeah I just got so excited I've never
seen your Brad Pitt okay I don't want a
morning radio you but all good
um all good you are
um
yeah the Brad Pitt impression like the
the tough thing on the show was because
my impression comes of like absolute
worship like that's a man that's a cool
handsome we're so similar like that is
it yeah um and so the the impression
wasn't like making fun of it was like
I'll be closer to it wait does he not
like it
I don't know I don't know if he has ever
seen it but but I'm just talking about
like for SNL finding the funny hook you
know what I mean yeah it was tricky and
my only answer for it was to put him in
the Brad Pitt shouldn't be there you
know so it was like Brad Pitt weatherman
and the one sketch I wrote that I liked
but showed it
um was Brad Pitt loves horses Brad Pitt
shouldn't be there you know it's just
like a bit but Brad Pitt loves horses
Brad Pitt loves horses were where he
there's a mystery about his past and it
comes out through the sketch that he was
rescued by a horse as a young boy and
he's got an obsession and he has all
these impressive world leaders as guests
but all he wants to talk about is
Palomino
beautiful horse wonderful horse gentle
golden Burr
and it also
there's the scene of him and him and
Morgan are at the bar and he's like you
know what
I don't think you're quitting because
you believe that I think you want to
believe that it's because you're
quitting you want me to agree with you
and say yeah yeah yeah it's [__]
twitch love
go [__] live in log cabins
but I don't agree with you I do not
thank you for the beer and it's that and
then the ba is more 12 Monkeys I see
what you want you want to escape that's
saying that's very same
it's just that thing Hazel so what is in
my chair
yeah
I don't care if I'm morning radio dude
that was the happiest I've been all day
summer is in full swing you guys it is
here and I am so happy to say that my
family and I have been spending so much
more time together Outdoors enjoying the
warm weather and just having simple
legit fun in the fresh air thanks to our
friends at electric e-bikes like
electric but electric e-bikes and just
in time electric is bringing you fast
and fresh new ride the XP 3.0 their
latest e-bike model featuring new
hydraulic brakes snag your new electric
XP 3.0 e-bike this month and experience
what I'm talking about Freedom like
never before I got Val and Expedition
which is their cargo bike with the plus
one seat which she can hold on to or
Leela can hold on to and we love it it's
super comfortable it's well built it's
sturdy and it runs so smooth and picks
up really fast it made me cackle with
joy way when I saw how easy it was just
to turn my wrist and start moving or you
can use it with the pedal assist on
which is like The Best of Both Worlds
you pedal like a manual bike but it
assists you the battery and the motor
assists you and you just go faster and
easier it's fun the batteries last a
really really long time the one we have
the Expedition has two batteries which
is incredible so you can really go a
long distance and it gets us outside
laughing and playing together we use it
for errands go you can go all the way to
the beach from where we live which is
incredible running to the grocery store
because it has the cargo basket which is
awesome when we forget something we just
want to make a small run or just going
for a cruise and having like I said just
old school outdoor but it's like old
school new school it's like a new way to
ride a bike and we are loving it the
most legit fun I've had in a long time
and the electric e-bike was created with
a mode of transportation that anyone can
can ride with quality feature filled
models Finance as low as 73 dollars a
month your adventure will not cost a
fortune they include a powerful
removable battery a bright LCD display
seven speed gearing and five levels of
pedal assist to power your ride electric
e-bikes are foldable and ship free fully
assembled it's truly cool you cut open
the box you basically roll it out and
you're ready to go so ReDiscover your
Independence this summer with an XP 3.0
from Electric you can visit
electricebikes.com to learn more and
explore the Epic models electric has to
offer that's
l-e-c-t-r-i-c-e-b-i-k-e-s.com
electricebikes.com also were brought to
us by a real game changer in my life is
ritual multivitamins you guys know you
can talk fantasy football with your
friends all day but asking them for
health advice not so much it's not
really the move ritual takes all the
guesswork out of the Vita game there are
multivitamins for men is based on
science to help fill common nutrient
gaps in the diet and level up your
nutrient goals it's an all-around win I
had so many gaps in my diet I'm always
experimenting with what to eat and
ritual brought me from a deficit to when
I go to the doctor bam 100 hundred
hundred hundred filling those gaps I can
tell you it absolutely works so many
people feel like a multivitamin you just
pee it out right you just pee it out
that's the criticism I hear ritual
multivitamin is different has a delayed
release which means it breaks down in
your intestine which is where it can be
absorbed directly into your body
scientifically developed with high
quality key ingredients and clean
bioavailable forms ritual is a new type
of two a day from helping support heart
health with omega-3 DHA to normal muscle
function to normal immune function with
vitamin D3 this small step can have a
Major Impact it's made traceable it's
vegan friendly non-GMO sugar-free gluten
Free Major allergen free I also
appreciate that it's fasting friendly if
you take it on an empty stomach
something like zinc can upset your
stomach but again it has a delayed
release so it's not going to upset your
stomach and a minty Essence in every
every bottle keeps things fresh and
makes taking your multivitamin a thing
you actually enjoy and look forward to
so do what I do guys I've been on the
ritual train for a long time I take
their probiotic as well uh and they're
essential for men two times two pills
once a day essential for men is a
quality multivitamin from a company you
can actually trust and get this ritual
is offering weirdos 20 off 20 during
your first month Go to ritual.com weird
to start ritual or add essential for men
to your subscription today that's
ritual.com weird all right let's get
back to Taryn
that was the happiest I've been all day
I okay I didn't until you started doing
it two things one he talks a little like
Macaulay Culkin
interesting I feel it I feel Culkin okay
I don't even know what I mean
yeah but oh they both talk like they
have something in their mouth he kind of
almost I guess
Pete Holmes funny guy Rico doing the
podcast now
we'll get into it
too
I used to do an impression of Brad Pitt
laughing okay because it's this
[Applause]
please it's a very h-a-h-a that's him
and uh Jesse James uh oh why are you
still stuck in a fight club why are you
still sucking air with so many of my
friends are
um cut you like a fish I can hear it I'm
never gonna do it I'm never gonna do it
nobody's asking me to do Impressions but
yours is incredible the thrill of it is
you don't even know that you know how
they sound so the joy of an impression
for a person hearing them yeah is you're
actually teleporting them to a moment so
that's why a beloved person like Brad
Pitt is a little bit more fun because
you're taking me back to like a time
when I was transfixed and you just made
me realize I didn't really know I knew
something it's very interesting it's
like time travel or something it is
fascinating yeah it is it to me I
because Impressions have always kind of
come easily I've always been quite
dismissive of them in my own life I
think it's a party trick it's whatever
silly yeah I'll take that because you're
a Music Theater guy and that's that's
the thing is that the musicality of it
that's right I can appreciate and I put
value into you're like a well-tuned
piano sure so when you can go yeah
yeah
I mean I see him he's stumbling
what about the guy I'm thinking I'm back
so great and I'm thinking about the guy
who owns the um
the Deadwood guy
Ian McShane is that his name yeah
Mr he wrote in on a cloud of fire you
[__] yeah but then in Wick he's a
little more Debonair you're right right
the Continental content yeah I mean
that's a good devil voice that's a great
devil voice McShane him and sexy beast
that was like the first time that I like
who is this guy it's funny that dude I
was just thinking this week would The
Devil's Advocate have been better if it
was Ian McShane oh God I don't know
because as you were doing your Pacino
one of my ends is I have so many names
call me dad wow you know it's that
incense very funny but he's not a snitch
yeah yeah yeah
[__] you too [__] you oh so good oh God
yeah all right
ever see a ghost no ever almost die
no
but yeah uh yeah I got really scared
recently that's the hesitation we went
snowboarding in uh Jackson Hole Wyoming
and I hadn't been a while
and I ask you where a lot of people in
the slopes like I just left
on your ski trip well no but but you
you're a lot of like yeah it's great hey
welcome no it's a really nice place you
know yeah you're right Julia
Louis-Dreyfus owns a house here
I heard that three or four times that's
a big selling point for that
um uh got up went to the went to the you
know took a couple easy runs started to
get comfortable again grew up
snowboarding haven't been now in almost
a decade probably and we went up and
just the first turn caught the back heel
and slammed my head and half my vision
went yellow and immediately I'm thinking
like
every horrible ski trip accident fluke
accident like yeah they didn't hit them
hit their hard head that hard you know
and then it's like just on the slips so
I was nervous then so that's the closest
I flipped why did you slip so I did I
turned onto the back side and I and my
back heel caught the edge and it just
like Wham flat like flopped me down
against the snow and like I had a helmet
on for it of course but it just I never
like half just bright yellow don't of
course that's Maverick see this is why
you need a helmet yeah you need a helmet
Maverick unless you're in heaven
[Music]
there are no helmets in heaven
hell is all helmets and your hair keeps
getting caught in the in the wind
creases the chin the chin skin gets
pinched in the clip how is it 2023 when
we haven't cracked helmets Yeah yeah
yeah just make a comfortable helmet just
make a nice soft easy smooth jelly
filled helmet
okay uh jelly head
what is that over and over I needed
helmets you're a [__] you must be
filled with soft Gucci jelly helmet you
really nailed it you don't know that
song jelly head I thought we were doing
the Fred and Kristen thing
we kind of were it was just one of my
favorite bits ever he did it on the show
oh did it for you here yeah yeah so now
and I do it all the time it's the best
you want to do it just for fun sure
please sir please sir please
I'm not doing the song yet I thought we
were doing the full characters
This song is called
podcast in Pals
when you're asked to a show
Fairly you know him barely you sit on
his couch while Katie Giggles laugh
that's Katie sweet Katie
because you love comic books
is
[Laughter]
that was the best when they switched the
tempo like that and they just get real
it's so joyful that's what I'm saying
yeah that's
and when you did it are now both fond
memories for me because it's Joy why
would we not go for it so fun thank you
for doing that yeah all right so you
when your vision went yellow how long
did it take before it came back I had a
headache the rest of the day and I was I
was probably concussed it was like my
first concussion and felt like a little
nauseous too but did you go to the
hospital no no no man
has a house up here I remember when I
did this for jld
she thought she almost died too she
ended up using that on Pete Holmes
podcast okay
you almost died and you didn't go to the
doctor and you were probably concussed
yeah
all right let's look at the notes okay
do you have a
Naked Gun story yes hit it
Yours Truly uh has been an active sag
member since 1992
um the thing that got me uh sag at that
time SAG eligible was
um I did a guest star for the
reenactments of Unsolved Mysteries which
shot in Big Bear my hometown where I was
living shut up yeah I was in one of the
reenactments and it was really nice it
was like a Christmas episode about World
War II coincidentally and it was about
this mother and her young son in a cabin
in during like Battle of the Bulge in
the wilderness and it's Christmas Eve
and there's a knock at the door and it's
three American soldiers and they're like
and the mother's like come in come in of
course we'll house you we'll feed you
you can sleep you can Slumber and the
sun's taking all him his name's Fritz
that's what I played and then an hour
later another knock it's four German
soldiers
and the mother says we have American
soldiers here it is Christmas Eve I will
not have any fighting in my house you
leave your weapons outside if you want
you can come in have a warm sleep have a
delicious meal but then you have to go
and they did and these Germans and
American soldiers broke bread at this in
this little cabin in Belgium I guess you
know and and
um and it was peaceful and in the
morning the Germans told the Americans
how to get back to their line to the
American line and they shook hands and
they split ways and that amazing like
now and the phase I'm in I'm like can't
believe I was so lucky to get to help
tell that story so Fritz grown up wanted
to try to track down who those soldiers
were and they found some of them yeah
whoa I know amazing I love stories like
that it's it was so it was such a
pleasant unsalmistry so this does
connected to it the mystery is like and
he's still out there her body hasn't
been seen since and so Bob stack that's
my uncle it's my mom's uncle by marriage
he's the host he's the host T was the
original Elliot Ness and he's in
airplane and oh yeah yeah got the
glasses yeah yeah
um please don't call me Shirley no
that's no that that's yeah exactly
um so when I auditioned for that knowing
that my uncle's a host they're I'm like
I know you're feeling this my hometown
but you know my uncle's Robert Stack I
said that in the room oh and like
directed and they're like we know Taryn
what do you do you think that'll help
you or something and I was like couldn't
hurt and they love telling that story so
through production they're like you know
this kid
couldn't hurt you're the couldn't hurt
precocious little obnoxious little
[__] what a fantastic but that got me
my taft-hartley right that made me SAG
eligible
and so then I went in an audition for
Naked Gun 33 in a third and it was to be
like the Joe Mazzello part in Jurassic
Park like the little kid but it's
geriatric Park it's not dinosaurs it's
80 foot tall old people with Walkers so
I remember this so I played the little
boy in the thing and that got me my side
card and I had a line I go like what was
that did you hear that and we look at
the cups and it's shaking and we look
out the window and it's an 84. but old
man who smashes the Sam Neal look-alike
can we go
but in the movie they cut my line and
they and the director kept going Taryn
Taryn it looks like you're smiling
because I was having the time of my life
because I was like I'm on a Jurassic
Park set I'm on a movie I get it like
and they're like Taryn still looks like
you're smiling okay you're really afraid
I've worked with a couple kid actors and
that was a big thing yeah don't watch
the show yeah
it's a terrible thing to tell a child
stop enjoying the show exactly no be
present wait the set wasn't
disappointing that seems like it would
be a deeply disappoint really oh so cool
it was at um it was at the the rally
Studios that are across the street from
Paramount uh-huh and it's they had a
whole Sound Stage and and ours was a our
piece was a clip in like the fake Oster
Oscars the the climax there's a bomb and
an envelope at the Oscars that's the
third Act of Naked Gun 33 in the third
and so they're showing clips of
different movies and there was a Mother
Teresa musical clip and the Sound Stage
was half the set of Mother Teresa's
wherever she's healing people at that
point and then half was like the jungle
outside the T-Rex cage of Jurassic Park
and they had the car that looked really
similar to the SUV like so magical so
fun wow so I did that and then I got to
go to the premiere and it was at the Fox
Theater in Westwood and my Uncle Bob was
like you're have you seen Leslie tell
him Bob says hi I'll go over and say hi
and I was like okay okay
I go to the theater and
um he's sitting in like the back towards
the back and there's a line of people
you know there's like people waiting to
greet him and I wait my turn and I'm by
myself and I'm 12 or whatever and my
mom's saving our seats and I finally get
up to him I go hey hi Mr Nielsen I'm
tearing them I'm in this movie my
uncle's Robert Stack and he said he told
me to say hi to you so I'm just that's
I'm saying hi and he's done fun to be in
the movie
and he goes
what
what did he say I couldn't hear a word
he said
and it took like all my courage to like
say that I'm like
Robert Robert Stacks my own goal I'm
Taryn I'm in this movie
let me yell into this old man he goes oh
oh Bob oh great guy great guy well happy
you're here and I walk back in shame to
my seat and I sit down one goes I go
fine
fine don't ask me about it it was
embarrassing and to Leslie Nielsen's
credit after the movie in the lobby he
saw me and he's like hey did you like
the movie did you enjoy it all right
well great job you know very classy
this is no exaggeration no hyperbole the
next week I'm at home watching say by
the Bell or whatever and a commercial
comes on and Leslie Nielsen is the
spokesperson for hearing aid
and I went
oh
[Applause]
myself in that moment I was like
it wasn't me
you're controlling the universe
like I thought it turns out this whole
thing is for you what
Leslie Nielsen was so important to me
because he he didn't look like my father
but he looked enough like my father yeah
that I was like that's my dad if my dad
was only a silly being my dad would
occasionally be a silly bean yeah funny
guy but this was like this guy will do
anything to make us laugh and what is
better than a grown man
willing to make anything as an Umpire at
a baseball game yeah
that remember the guy that goes hey
that's Nico Palazzo
is that in the first one it's in the
first one I don't remember this is I
don't know why I'm telling well because
he's break dancing and he takes his mask
off and it's he's saying the national
anthem
the guy who stands up and goes hey
that's Nico Palazzo he is a villain in
uh peewee's Big Adventure
it's a random little fact it's oh it's
what's the guy's name the rich kid Lewis
or Lewis
hello p Phillip Phillip yeah Philip
something like that yeah
I said two very different names but I
feel like I could make either one work I
loved it can I ask you and please
forgive me if you've been asked as a
million but it seems to me that the King
George Part in Hamilton would be a
snooze because you have to wait so long
it is easy as pie so rewarding but you
have to be in like if it was just the
first one you go like let's go get sushi
there's enough there's several yeah I
have the timing out it worked out once
there's
two in the first half and then one in
the the second half second act uh four
dum-dums yeah I know I do I fluctuate
between sports and and oh I see it all
the time yeah half time or intermission
I just took my girls doing Angel City
game on Monday it was great it was so
fun and
my oldest was like is there an
intermission
yeah yeah exactly intermission uh but
the first yeah so but there was it's
like 25 minutes between the first two
songs and then a little bit shorter and
then you're in The Ensemble at the very
end for the last two and a half songs or
something like that it was great I was
oh you're in Overjoyed yeah I become an
ensemble member for that wait in the
costume no in in the plain clothes sort
of colonial yeah Colonial beige oh every
part of the Buffalo yeah exactly I never
considered that uh King George is taking
that makeup off and joining the regular
during the bullet you know the sky and
so you're there sitting for that and
then you're part of the who die Who
Lives who dies who tells your story
history oh I'm sorry
lin-manuel Miranda tells your story yeah
that's kind of a self-serving song who
will ride the musical that's all right
if it's that good yeah you've earned a
little bit you've earned it baby
lin-manuel yeah no harm no foul yeah
that's okay but that is talk about John
Wick energy that is a type of confidence
where you're like not only am I writing
a musical but the musical itself
acknowledges how great the music is
totally yeah yeah yeah
um and did anything ever goofy I mean
Live Theater the only time that because
the great thing about the king role is
like there's so much anticipation for it
and by the time I joined the show the
album was out it was the biggest thing
in the world it was like I was like I
can't believe I'm Charlie in the
Chocolate Factory like this is insane
and you come out and a message from the
cake a message from the King and like
you're there and Spotlight and The Crowd
Goes Wild yeah every time yeah I did I
did 99 performances I almost made it to
100 and I called out sick once and I
regret it to this day but there was a
Sunday matinee where it came out there's
this message from the King a message
from the King silence
just silence just just a very
polite polite thoughtful watching
audience you know
and it threw me a little bit but I got
through it and I got back off stage and
everyone was like what did you do like
they'd never you made it happen were you
making swastics
somehow yeah yeah like yeah so that was
really fun and then they do a great
thing called ham for ham
which is
um ten dollars there's a ten dollar uh
uh Lottery and you the first two rows
are for ten bucks but they do no that
edu ham is what I'm thinking of
every first Saturday something like that
all public schools in the New York area
greater New York area have to study and
do a a presentation about the American
Revolution they come each school has a
winner that represents their school and
performs a five minute piece could be
musical a scene a sketch or whatever
they do it on the stage they go have
lunch and they come back and we do a
matinee performance just for them whoa
so it's the coolest thing and then and
it's a different energy it's a different
vibe it's so excited very vocal very but
really you know rxious but so fun and
that's where I flubbed the best because
the song it's the same song three times
with different lyrics yeah so
occasionally be like and I was pretty
good about it it almost seems harder
there's a trickiness yeah yeah
especially if you get into like a Fugue
State and you're just going on autopilot
and you're like wait which one is this
yeah Oceans Rise Empire's fall sets up
the same verse but you have to remember
where you are in the show yeah right but
I just rolled my R1 so I was like
remember we made an arrangement when you
went away and I just in my head was like
what are you doing that's a big role and
completely lost as I went away
and you hear you hear 1300 high school
students go oh
damn
and I just because you're blanking yep
and I go
I'm your man I just said nothing in that
space till that point it got me back on
track
who is Splendid it was really Splendid I
was like remember we made an arrangement
when you into a
I'm dead I'm Your Man
I'm dead it was great it was really
great I'm your man it'll be now what I
say if I'm blanking I'm your man
wow yeah okay Ruffalo Ruffalo back to
the Ruffalo at all whatever you remember
your bicorn
those told this story not even by
Ruffalo himself
but I was at this game night and they're
like I heard crazy story Ruffalo does
this play he's getting all the plaudits
in the world it's basically what gets
him his first strawberries like this is
the show to see it's him and two female
roles it's three person play and they're
eating it up and and one day uh one one
of the performances stage manager comes
back and goes Bill Murray's in the house
and Mark goes oh man I'm gonna give it
Bill Murray's about to get the best
performance of my best role right now
and he puts it all out there and and as
I this person who told it to another
person who told it to me says Mark knew
he nailed it Mark it was like it was
everything he wanted to be more every
tear every ounce of sweat spittle it was
all out there
come backstage after the show Bill comes
to say hi says to one woman
that was maybe the best performance I've
ever seen on stage thank you says the
next one
I am not a crier but your moment in the
show made me
outwardly cry I couldn't believe it
thank you thank you and he looks to Mark
ruffle and goes you're up and walks out
it's almost like a sorbet that story
it's like so
unexpected but it's kind of like start
there's times
there's no real yeah but I love a story
it subverts expectation yeah perfectly
yeah and he's the celebrity who gets
away with that if you want us or or or
that it's not like you're not
immediately Furious you're gonna like is
he is that funny is that did he do is it
but he doesn't think the reason why you
can call you can call I'm not saying I'm
calling it Okay the reason you can call
fair play on it is it's because it's a
destruction of ego story yes so it's a
guy who's already his train has already
come in ruffalo's doing great yep he and
he kills it yes and obviously Bill
Murray loved it for sure it's not he so
he's high expected that's true so the
joke is to then imagine if you said yes
Europe yeah and walked out yes because
and what what I I mean I I don't even
need to analyze it anymore I think
that's why you can enjoy that story yes
okay tell me a name droppy Taran kill
him story who a name droppy
like you know I mean you're on a
Saturday what's the end Saturday evening
happening Saturday evening post um
yes I was in the post I was in the Ron
Howard film the post I mean you had to
have I remember mullaney's story when he
was with Mick Jagger
and he was like trying to they were
writing a song
and he goes
Melanie obviously would tell it better
but he was like we need something that
rhymes with like more yeah and John goes
score and he goes no
like he's really no and then Melanie
goes a door and he goes yay
[Laughter]
like
to us equal like amazing they're both
equal but for some reason Mick Jagger's
like yeah and loves it I got a good Mick
Jagger one which was it's not like
shocking or anything but it just is like
this is arguably the biggest rock star
in the world yeah
and he's hosting a comedy show
he owes everybody nothing well that's
what Melanie said too he talks like Alex
like he talks to people like you talk to
Alexa
that's mullaney's bed he just goes Diet
Coke
do you say please to Alexa and you know
what I do now you do thank you I
appreciate that you know it's those
little touches well my I my experience
was like I I was not one to try to Buddy
up I did like that's it just is not in
my nature it's like if we work on
something we'll collaborate we'll get to
know each other that way if not I'm not
gonna yeah sing and dance for you yeah
um but I was in a sketch with him and I
was impressed by how committed he was
like how he was trying because he's
going like
all right he's playing literally like a
businessman going out for sushi after a
meter or whatever you know like they're
out on the town he's like all right I've
got to find my voice I've gotta find I
gotta find my voice what is what's this
character's name Tom Tom Tom but if I do
this I don't really sound like a Tom do
I sound like a tall I sound more like a
Kevin
Kevin yeah that's it it's a writer over
and they changed the character name to
Kevin to help Mick Jagger find his oh he
didn't keep looking for Tom no
tomboys Kevin eat I'm more of a cabin
I don't know that the character name is
uttered outside of like the opening
Exposition lines with that sketch but
that was his process like that is like
you're a rock star man like you do
anything it's how you do everything
right I guess so I mean that yeah
exactly right I'm not surprised it's
like people at that level tend to
somebody told me like Will Smith oh that
it was James Corden he was like Tom
Cruise Will Smith he's like when they're
doing something it's the only thing in
the world they're doing yeah and he's
like and that's the the number one thing
you see yes with like highly highly
functioning people totally yeah I
believe I've seen it yeah well and I
gave you a Mick Jagger one right
whatever came to mind
I mean for me like my biggest like oh
crap is is Jim Carrey just because he
was it and and still is quite honestly
like in terms of like comedic influences
in my life it's funny you say him
because uh Ben Schwartz was uh you know
Sonic yeah what was that like I I know I
think he was on set acting with him but
he was like he's not doing it as a joke
at all he's Dr Robotnik in the same way
Mick Jagger is Kevin oh amazing like
he's doing it a hundred percent yes
that's all that exists there's no yes
Liar Liar it's just I'm Dr Robotnik
today any and he delivers and he's all
in yeah and it's the only way to not be
embarrassed isn't it funny that like
playing it cool is more likely to make
you embarrassed but yeah really do it
yeah although I can see you thinking of
count counterpoints that only is true
only because I feel like Bobby told it
on this podcast the Ted Danson story The
Ted dancing came back I think he told it
on this one I think I don't know but
dead dancing they're shooting Mr Mayor
and like Ted's doing a big scene and
then he comes back to videos you just
mentioned Mr Mayor a con synchronous oh
funny yeah and then he comes back and he
sits in the chair instead dancing very
accomplishing
ah isn't acting embarrassing yeah
I love that so much because that's much
more how I am on set I know what you
mean I was speaking of Street Fighter
there's a Street Fighter movie that has
the guy from American Pie in it Chris
Klein Chris Klein and he yeah and and
the girl from Smallville yes and she's
Shun Lee Legend of Chun Li and Neil
McDonough is and bison yes from Band of
Brothers World War II oh wow Everything
is Everything we just fell into a real
everything everywhere all at once yes we
did
uh
sorry I was Chris Klein is
I was like there is a no I'm not even
gonna say his his oh oh that that movie
uh you don't have to be stoned I don't I
don't really smoke pot anymore yeah you
can watch that movie like your stone and
you'll enjoy the [__] out of it okay
okay cool so
I don't want to say it's bad it's just
Earnest and going for it and it's just
kind of like the Mark Ruffalo story it
shows you that like sometimes Swagger is
the stupidest thing in the world and
Chris Klein is like this guy walks
through raindrops and you're just like
beautiful poor guy
maybe it would have worked but not in
this movie my favorite thing online
maybe top three easily is his audition
for Mamma Mia
no it's not I want to be on the record
like I'm the casting office that leaked
this can we watch it burn in hell can we
watch it Chris how long is it very very
it's worth watching and so I mean edit
it out if you want but Chris Klein's
when we audition because I relate to it
so much but it is not a great audition
he's very vulnerable it's a singing
audition oh no oh no and like shame on
the casting
it's the top one the the bottom one's
like a silly response that he made oh he
knows he knows it's it's I relate to it
oh I'm so familiar it it makes me it
makes me laugh it's the stuff of
nightmares but it makes me
love him it makes me love him yeah it
makes me go bro
thank you I'm sorry that this happened
to you and that you're the face of it
and it is hilarious and we missed a
couple marks for sure yes but
hundred times have I been there for sure
it's also a movie here I'll be his agent
not as a character but his agent I
should say like it's a movie you'll re
you'll pre-record it it's not live like
you'll nail it they'll fix it it'll be
fine he still could have booked it from
that totally but can I just say nothing
to me feels more Show Business than than
the bad part of show business because
when you're feeling viral and ready to
go and confident and on the money and
Bam you hit your mark and you nail it
nothing better same situation but you
your Mojo's off like something's wrong
physically wrong emotionally wrong
whatever it is you go out and it's wrong
that to me what that feels like is being
in that audition you're starting to
listen yes you're wearing a v-neck
t-shirt with a necklace and a leather
jacket and you're doing the scene and
there's this nice little reprieve from
having to sing this difficult song and
then Dong Dong like the piano kicks back
in and you have to be like I told you
I have to go back in the show must go on
and to add to that a little drizzle of
he's above everybody yeah you're I have
to act dead dancing down I've never you
like you sing down in a room if you're
on stage and you're a rock star you sing
down yeah but the no it's the angle of
the end it's also a stupid
like the song is kind of stupid it's
Abba man yeah
yeah it's not like like super cool it's
like
a bleach blonde He-Man cut in purple
sunglasses and two Norwegian women
that's how that song is sung that's the
only way it should be sung and this poor
man was forced to sing it but he became
an avatar for all of us because it's so
true in this very office I I did a
singing audition and if you saw it was
look I didn't send it it was a self tape
so I didn't send it until I felt good
about it yeah yeah but is there anything
more vulnerable no than singing in
Earnest no no
no
no I did I did in summer by Olaf oh
great by Olaf I think I think I think
In Summer by Olaf
uh
uh what you were about to tell me a
story though
Jim Jim
sorry man I I just I stopped
interviewing you halfway through now
we're just hanging out it's great I love
it okay good freaking love it
um Jim hosted my first season I got a
sketch on with him we played these like
possessed animatronic things that like
in a creepy carnival so it's like
physical comedy and then when the bit's
done you lower behind a wall so there's
like a little plywood wall that you
scratch behind and it's just like that
first time of like doing it at dress got
a great response I crouched down Bill
haters to my right he's like it's gone
great man and then like look over and
it's just my hero yeah it's just Crouch
going like
you know is the best it was the best it
was the best and I was like
what what else yeah what else what else
um and so like that was really happy but
he's such an Explorer he's constantly
like trying to improve and pitch and
with SNL it's like okay well we're going
live in 11 30 so why don't we try it the
way it's written and then what so I
think for the writers there was some
struggle there on that end yeah and and
at the 40th at SNL 40th
he was in Celebrity Jeopardy I did like
a Christoph Waltz impression he was
doing Matthew McConaughey but it's they
had like a revolving door and you've got
feral and you've got Norm McDonald and
you've got Daryl Hammond like you've got
everybody and Jim was rehearsing it and
going through it again and again and
again and again and taking up time you
know and and yeah and trying to make it
the best it could be yeah but it was
like he was getting more time doing that
than anybody else right and then on the
show he went up a little bit like you
wouldn't even notice but there was a car
there's a flub or whatever right and
again very similar to Chris Klein thing
like that humbling was so beautiful
whereas like he worked so hard to make
it the precise thing and then the fickle
that's the fickleness of SNL like a
fumble and backstage he was like yeah
man you know you love it you want to get
it back but but that's the beauty of the
show you know it's just out there and I
took that my sees that moment in that
like vulnerable like
yes you're human too but you're still my
idol yeah and I went I dude it's fine
and that's cool to hear you say I have
to tell you my whole life has just been
like mimicking you on the playground to
make friends like that's what you are to
me like dressing up as you at Halloween
three Halloween's in a row like yeah and
he was like oh man I oh that's awesome
that's how you yeah I I hear you I hear
you cause I look down and this comes
full circle he goes uh because I look I
I feel the same way you know I look down
that Hall and I go that's Bill [__]
Murray
wow and I was like
this is the best anime
don't worry walks by and goes
okay couple things one
what I love about that story so I just
take my special a couple weekends ago
and the first question thank you the air
conditioning was off I bet the people
that were there were like it was still
great but to me I was so wet I was like
this is unusable okay and then the
second show thankfully was magic and
great probably even informed by the fact
that we didn't have two shows to pull
from so yeah it's all on the line that
brought me to life yeah but the first
show
really got me back in touch with that
humility and you forget how precious it
is how precious low-level suffering can
even be yes like you go off stage and
you're like that is not I've been
focusing on this for months to the point
where like I won't even tell you how
obsessive I get where I'm like how can I
make sure I'm in the best mood possible
it sounds like I do drugs I just mean
like I'm gonna take fiber like this time
so I'll have a good poop before the show
all that stuff it worked by the way yeah
nice all this stuff and then I swept my
way through and I'm like I'm like this
is unusable and and but it brought me
back in touch with everybody suffering
so when I watch that Chris Klein I'm
actually relating oh absolutely and then
humiliate humble and human are all from
the same root which I believe is soil uh
Human coming from the soil going low to
the soil all that sort of stuff I could
be wrong about that but isn't that fun
that it's not just part of Being Human
it's like the root of being human is
that where these Divine elegant dancers
painters writers yes we love we create
all this stuff but the core of us is
you're always one bad lunch and a bad
night's sleep away from I told you
smoking was my own yes that connects us
yeah it's actually gorgeous so your
story so the point is
what did I say about Chris Klein he
could have still done it because those
movies you pre-record the song yeah yeah
yeah but Jim was doing it on SNL and
that's the purity of that show is like
yeah and now it exists yeah so like it
it counts yes and we include the
humiliation yes and that and that's why
stand up can be exciting and why life
theater can be exciting too absolutely
yeah I mean they they edit stuff yeah
yeah what do you mean eventually like
eventually like if they re-release
anything or if they you know something
taboo or shocking or whatever happened
on the East Coast they'd cut it out for
the West Coast you know what a shame
yeah yeah but you I thought I was done
with those but I'm Stewie on the set of
uh the kid show on Family Guy yeah he
goes to Teletubbies okay Stewie wants to
go to where they where they shoot a
Teletubbies show and he realizes it's
just guys in costumes on a set funny
like breaks his heart you just did that
to me a little bit sorry no I loved it I
have to grow it it's very minimal it is
mostly live I have to learn no don't
don't walk it back I also just was
mentioning Jim
because I we're almost done so we don't
have to open up this whole can of worms
but like I my relationship with my
parents can be so complicated because I
love them and because sometimes we just
don't gel in in the way that I know we
both want to I was watching this talk
that Jim Carrey was giving
as part of an Eckhart Tolle event it was
on Eckhart Tolle's YouTube this Jim
Carrey thing and I'd seen it a million
times but I watched it again and he
talked about with his mom
uh he was like she was depressed and
maybe even bipolar I don't know and he
was like I thought if I could be special
I would make her life meaningful he's
like because look you your life isn't
meaningless you made me and I'm
extraordinary yeah and I was like oh God
like shaving with the sharpest razor
like I just I feel like I need cold
water on my face but I was like what
another like he's not only a performer
but he'll be vulnerable in that way it
really gave language to
there's a burden
and again we're telling imperfect
stories in an imperfect world and
everybody did the best they could and
there is a burden to being like a
special shiny son yes that is unspoken
and there's this Carl Young quote where
it's like the greatest burden you can
put on a child is the unfulfilled dream
of the parent oh boy and but you should
also keep that in your in your you know
crawl for my kids in your craft for you
because yeah
there is time for sacrifice I say no to
things and I am around and I I love my
balance and it's valuable that uh her
mom is going after her things and her
dad is going after her things yeah and
it's also a wonderful privilege that so
many people we know are just doing their
thing like they overcame resistance and
they're going for it yeah so that's
really valuable I think my poor mom and
I mean that sincerely I don't think that
was explained I don't know if that was
even if she had enough time and Leisure
to even consider that she was just doing
what she could to be the best mom she
could she was made from a mom 20 30
years earlier from a mom you know yeah
exactly just like the movies yeah
exactly written by the 80s bullies
exactly uh sorry I just wanted to share
that because I love that no it's
beautiful yeah do you have any thoughts
on the meaning of life do you have any
Vibe one way or the other I will yeah I
mean I will I'm I'm Vibe very agnostic
um
I I I'm pretty strong and you know
I think when we die we decompose and
that's it and and where that might
instill fear concern or stress it really
makes life in every moment so Matt so
beautiful yeah what what a lottery win
it is to
breathe walk exist be conscious by the
way can I add to that sure you don't
have to be tear and kill him on SNL any
moment that you drop into fully and
really absolutely like a like a visiting
alien yeah and just driving in traffic
if you can do that you see the potential
for almost anything to like move all the
impediments out of the way and be fully
alive and that's the gift totally is
what I hear you saying yeah that's not
just your specialness it's just like oh
my God I'm not talking about any uh
statistical or Surface aspects of my
life specifically I mean to be is
a miraculous gift and so the meaning of
life I think is like you know
spread happiness and joy and try not to
hurt others yeah
[Music]
okay this is this has been a lot of fun
for me
no I don't want to be Michelangelo
I thought I don't yeah I never I know
Michelangelo's they are exhausted oh God
yes and I don't know if I believe it
grow up Hey Michelangelo grow up grow
the [__] up yeah and hey Casey Casey
Jones lighten up lighten up and hey Leo
not every moment has to be an
opportunity we're a team here buddy no I
in team and hey RAF RAF maybe lighten up
a little maybe maybe kind of clean your
room you know Focus yeah yeah yeah and
Donnie does coolness need rudeness
I
I don't know if they're mutually
exclusive you know
can I ask you a sincere question always
when AI is ruling the planet yes and
they have access to everything we ever
made okay do you think for real okay
that there will be
like a deification almost of Donatello
because he does machines
Seer like
this was the best of them
uh-huh no
in all sincerity in all earnestness no
yeah
he will have a place on top of AI
Mountain yes where he is there there's
there's servant he's their their you
know what I mean like I like
he he is there for on display for all to
see
and he came to live with that well
because he can do them so he's he is the
closest
you know organic creature to an AI and
there to problem solve for Rusty wires
yes I don't do machine panels cool and
rude yeah you're cool
and he will be hard at work because it
is his obsession and his passion but
occasionally he'll look down from the
mountain with shame and horror and like
look what yeah he did look what you have
begotten he should have seen it coming
the Technodrome he's he's the guy in
Terminator too
miles Bennett Tyson very good miles
penetration
very good mile Senate
very good miles about Tyson that movie I
think we were the same yeah
the same thing because Terminator 2 and
Batman it went Batman right to
Terminator two Terminator 2 first rated
our movie I saw in the theater
because he you know what a genius
mechanism that they that he says you
can't kill anybody
Terminator one is like a [__] snuff
movie yes yes it's like a gritty eight
millimeter [__] nightmare yes
Terminator two Jim Jimmy Cameron comes
in and goes I know how to fix this he
pairs up with a boy and the boy says
don't kill anyone and next thing you
know
we're jizz in Titanic Oh my God right I
I my memory of walking out of the
theater this is like a big big is doing
this walk in the parking lot can you
stop with my and go and just humming
[Music]
like this is me in the parking lot and I
went with my my best friend at the time
and his dad and his dad goes like
Taryn you sure do love singing the music
from everything
I went
now I know why I cry
[Laughter]
can I tell you
that whole time I was freaking out
because when I saw it I was walking a
vivid memory
walking down the hallway
at my school and I we were looking for
somebody and I did the scanning scanning
they're in the locker
and I got to the end of the hall
Susan my teacher yes said you looked
like the Terminator robot and I'm like
shut the [__] up suits I'm like like in
my mind I was like don't see yeah
I thought like you that you could just
do it and no one would notice I am the
terminator
Robert Patrick ah so good did you watch
light magic that documentary light and
Magic about ilm and the founding of it
and no oh Disney plus light and Magic uh
watch it right now in front of me
um it's but they talk about that that
movie Terminator 2 the way it Advanced
with CG and the liquid T1000 and and
Dennis murin talks about him moving
through the bars and he says in the
documentary something to the effect of
like to this day I watched that shot and
I go that's not possible
that's not possible it's a combination
of so many elements blending seamlessly
the physical thing Robert's person the
liquid CG coming that that starts as a
tangible person into the liquid into the
tangible but he's like I don't know how
we did that and then his gun catches
it's incredible Robert Patrick fun fact
practice not blinking when he shot his
gun because he was like why would a
robot blink cool Isn't that cool and if
you watch it he doesn't blink he does a
couple times have you seen this boy
and then
yeah
that's the same
we are the same yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah if you
oh that was fun you know what I get
obsessed with too is in The Matrix when
uh twitch goes not like these
not like this
that's another good death so many good
deaths not like this not like this
actually what a great way to do Joey
pants just to be unplugged in The Matrix
I guess that would be a great death I
guess that's the aneurysm of okay you're
just off
you'd rather go slow
no
no I don't live forever
right in your in your sleep yeah in your
sleep right this is
I want to blend I want to be in a
hospital bed I want the time to know I'm
dying and I would say no please I want
to get in touch with the experience yes
and then after I've had all of that on
my last night I want that not like this
okay yeah the first the first time that
I was overwhelmed by how much my child
loves me I I my kids are my everything
really because no not the same no not
the same kids oh they feel different the
rift was different no how old are your
kids
uh Fourteen and eight oh my God yeah
there's a separation there's we started
early oh that's not what I picked up on
it I just was picking up the earliness
early nice 45 she's out of the house wow
wow that first time I took him out for a
daddy-daughter date the 14 year old at
this time is probably a eight seven or
eight I'm gonna die and and she goes and
she's funny she's very curious and she's
very uh does not suffer fools right so
we're eating and she's like got her like
ice cream sundae she's like
Dad how do you want to die
and I went like how I did the parent
thing of like oh long time from now long
time she's like no but like how I was
like we don't need to worry about that
and she's like but how do you want to do
it like how do you want it and I'm like
well I think
again many years from now
very uh peacefully maybe we're at a like
a family property in Canada we have
stuff there maybe I'm at the house and I
can tell I'm sick
and you're there both my girls and meet
your families if you choose to have
families if you have everybody's there
we celebrate we look through pictures we
watch videos or something we laugh and
when I feel it's close you know Mommy
will be with me and maybe you girls come
and are laying on the bed and I'll close
my eyes and she's
[Music]
and start stopping in the middle of a
Ruth's Chris Steakhouse and I oh my God
I'm in such an idiot I'm sorry I'm sorry
I'm sorry you asked you entrapped me you
tricked me but I saw her really conceive
of what it was and how I like what I
mean to her yeah and it overwhelmed it
was overwhelming
I think that story is an A plus I see no
I see no mistakes there yeah yeah I I do
love it because it was like What if I
told the full story she's like I hope
it's tomorrow it's Matt golditch has
this great joke this uh comedian great
guy named Matt golden great guy great
guy great guy best guy both sides oh see
that's different see it's lower yeah
it's down really I mean Jay uh John
James Austin Johnson he's got he's got
the corrupt he he doesn't know he
doesn't like a little Scooby-Doo I mean
yeah it is Scooby-Doo
um
don't want to have a baby
um but another comedian who's great oh
man he has this great joke I hope he
doesn't mind me saying he goes my wife
my wife uh said to me uh this is a great
man call to check for me I had a dream
last night that you died and uh I'm like
um in the future I'd prefer if you refer
to those as nightmare
isn't that a great joke
you got the right exactly that's a
nightmare yeah what a beautiful story
well I'm so glad you had babies you're
such a thanks man such a great man
thank you I'm so thrilled that you did
the Pod thank you be here thank you for
having me I'll never forget that be prit
be prit but you're more about it Bradley
the Bradley pet how special is that I
love him how special do you watch Dave
Dave the show Dave that's another show I
should watch is it good yes really yes
listen to my list of shows okay bear
okay the new party down
yes yes great I haven't seen that one I
haven't heard either either way but I
love it the first one yep light and
Magic on Disney plus from you yes and
Dave because we just finished beef
oh how is that 10 out of 10. oh great
okay let's take it it's not succession a
meeting it's not trying to be succession
sure but what succession is it is for
what it is okay the quality yeah it's
that level quality action writing
directing cinematography it's perfect
damn okay that's great perfect thank you
and deeply satisfying in how it results
cool so it's not like and it kind of
Fizzles out of there so I think it's a
masterpiece wow yeah all right Flex I'm
in yeah yeah have you do watch the great
what's this the great is my favorite
show on TV right now tell me whatever
what it is l l Fanning and Nicholas Holt
she played it's the story it's Catherine
the Great on Hulu it's about a woman yes
you just hear me deleting it
um the great on Hulu the great is the
third season just came out okay it's
it's the same author the showrunner is
the guy who wrote the favorite the the
um Emma Stone film and Olivia Coleman
Oscar nominated the favorites
too many girl names yeah and when does a
man come in so the story is really cool
okay okay okay okay okay okay he plays
the Alexander yeah okay Russian leader
there's a lot of Russian dudes around
JK hundo percent JK JK I don't know I
came out like that uh okay so the great
okay so watch beef and I'll watch the
great and I want did you watch the bear
somebody told me the Bears I haven't
seen the bear
I hear it in your voice that it's only
okay not
it's not really for me
um
because when a show ends yeah
especially when you have a baby like
that's that special time what are we
there it's 8 45 what are we doing where
are we going to ending where we began
okay
since having a daughter and I I'm like a
70 30 feminine masculine person anyway
as I get older that gets I get more
masculine it just means more rigid more
rigid and and angry but when I'm and I
love being a dad more than anything and
I love being a husband more than
anything and there's just a lot of
female energy and a lot of times at the
end of the day that's when I'm like I
have to watch what's that one with Josh
Brolin where the bodies are in the walls
it's a sicario sicario yeah I I remember
I saw sicario when it was in the
theaters I was like that was okay and
now I'm like I have to watch this oh I
love sicario it's crazy at that family
table at that dinner table chills right
now
chills you know who Benicio is like
right
he's doing Brad yeah oh where Brad's
doing him right or there's just a type
of dude there's a bone structure lip
yeah I narrowness thing yeah is this it
but they also you know you've got you
got uh
you like dogs
there's that and then there's give me
the keys
for real man
so like they do that right they do a
similar thing too but
you know going anywhere jumpstood I want
you at some point to text me when it
hits you that I'm right that Macaulay
Culkin okay and Brad Pitt are doing
something similar okay because I can't
explain it to you today but a day is
coming in soon my friend ma'am I'm eight
years old do you think I'll be here by
myself I don't think so that's it right
yeah that's Brad Pitt I don't think so I
don't think so it's a cool way of
talking yeah that's right yeah which is
quiet yes Denzel too is that that's you
that's you all right all right okay okay
where you close your eyes and you're
like it is it Jay or the person you know
it's like it's crazy no Jay when he was
on we just did impressions for three
hours it was [__] or meaning he did
it was incredible yeah I like doing them
but when you and
I I don't want you to take this as a
backhand because I like doing them with
you but when it's that perfect you're
like I'm just not gonna play totally you
know what I mean yes absolutely oh no
it's just I can't be in this orgy yeah
yeah yeah yeah that's like like I I play
like pretty good acoustic guitar yeah
and he is like a concert technician yeah
he's Beethoven yeah yeah and we're white
dudes at a party that are like you guys
like Oasis
facts facts
um well get out of here oh the last
question is this is for you by the way
you didn't drink it that's your magic
mind oh amazing thing you're gonna love
it okay and this is new this is modern
mammals it's my favorite shampoo it's
incredible beautiful shampoo I wash my
hair today does it look like I wash my
hair today this isn't the commercial I'm
just really excited about this I'm
giving it to all my friends I'm like
like my hair is thinning that's my storm
a hat guy that's bad at like your hair
type isn't necessarily my hair type is
it
all I've been hearing all day is we're
the same so I don't know that's facts
can you float a bottle cap in your pubes
I'm just kidding I'm just uh you'll
still like it uh because you have to
wash your hair and it's I I love put in
your beer but in terms of your question
of does it look like I shampooed my hair
yeah you could show me
five pictures and be like do you have
and do you have it I'll be like no clue
yeah but when I wash my hair it's ruined
in what way and then it becomes stringy
dry it's like out of control okay when I
would wash my hair I'd literally take
olive oil and put it in my hair just to
give it something really interesting and
it's like almost like a dry shampoo now
it's just great thanks man envy that but
modern man let's add my pubes you can
put a bottle cap in it and you just put
it and you don't manscape or anything
when I was single I would give a little
trim okay just a little trim because
there would be like one way where yeah
like a Tim Burton movie Yes like a
branch and a Timber uncurling
Just uncurling as your pubic lice walk
down off of it oh my God doing jumps
the young ladies like should there be
lice doing jumps it's hard
I showered today and you haven't said
anything about it it's clean it's clean
can you tell me the time you laughed the
hardest in your life that's that's all
in my whole life or or to take the
pressure
um yeah it doesn't have to be number one
but if you got it you got it
you know I I've been very blessed with
hard laughs yeah you know uh seeing the
South Park movie in the theaters really
really hard like in the aisle oh my God
Uncle [__] like mind blown
the hardest that I laugh consistently is
if I'll do a game night with like my
college friends we play a game called
loaded questions we're not even friends
yet and I'm like why today
done done
loaded questions and the Sim the simple
way it's designed to be played is like
name five things that are like what's a
fruit that's purple right or or what no
sorry what's your favorite fruit I'm
thinking of a different game what's your
favorite fruit and you write down the
answer and someone says banana and and
the person who asked the question
doesn't answer I have all the answers to
you you tell me answers and I go okay
Pizza orange kitties grape anything
that's like um you ever played Dixit no
it's the greatest game of all time
similar mechanism okay it's all guessing
who do you think uh would have said this
funny okay and those are the best games
because you're playing the person
instead of the game but do you write the
answers in Dixit you're putting Dixon is
incredible and okay I'm not being paid
to say it's
it's somebody uh you have five cards and
they're all like oil paintings okay and
they're very abstract they're like dream
yes and let's you want to give a clue
that's obvious but not too obvious so
let's say mine is like a boy in a dunce
cap and he's fishing in a toilet yes I
might say like worst day ever okay okay
and then I put that down and now you
have five cards now you want to pick one
that would be worst day ever let's say
you have a dragon and and he's trying to
light a cigarette but he only smoke is
coming out okay you would put that down
okay maybe you have one that you don't
have but the fun comes when you're
guessing yes who do you think said this
who do you think is the original card
you're all trying to guess who what the
original card was you're trying to find
my card interesting so you want to get
people to guess your card so you want to
guess right okay but if you're if your
wife plays with you yes you'll know her
answers better than you'll know mine yes
because you'll be like I think you would
think this because you're a people
person and and nobody showed up to your
birthday party that's the worst day ever
yeah so it's like that fantastic game I
love it tell me about this one loaded
questions is uh the one place you
wouldn't want to go on vacation yes and
everybody writes down wherever it is and
the way you're supposed to play is like
you wouldn't want to go on vacation like
Death Valley or whatever
but way my friends and I play is it's
really like an improv show where people
built like like a you know it gets so
inappropriate and so offensive and it's
so blue and again you know
like sloppy gushy fat balls covered in
[__] mud the the you know like like just
like the most juvenile it's a 60 40
black of [__] it's a little sticky yeah
um you know which parts but the fun of
it is like not even the most bass or
offensive things it's just like like
there was a word two months ago like
gushy just like gushy tickled us so
funny that you'd be like you know
because sometimes then you then you
reverse engineer it and it's like your
favorite board game to play like gushy
Monopoly you know and so and just but
it's just it just builds over time to
where the answers are just absolute
nonsense that have nothing to do with
the question yes and we're just trying
to make each other laugh and that's
that's where I laughed the artist I love
it and no specific one I I just don't
want to end the story if you had the I
have no
I'm with you and believe it or not I
play meaning believe it or not meaning
yeah I don't know what I mean I have two
choices I guess oh yeah you have two
choices I just mean like it's so fun I
play with my in-laws and that's not
classically like a truly organic yes
it's just it's such a fun game cool that
you actually can like just draw and we
I've given so much [__] to my in-laws
because they know each other Val's
parents will get it and I'm like how is
a kitten reading the newspaper yeah
another day another dollar
when mine was literally a guy with a
briefcase walking into a bag
why wouldn't you pick my and I mean it
just drives you insane amazing uh but
deeply fun well Taryn
if I ever want to do another podcast
it'll be with you great
and depending on how long the strike is
maybe maybe here for me in September
what do you think August
when does the pile diminish yeah we go
50 50. yeah yeah what would it be about
we can't it can't just be pop culture
but yeah it'll be called same guy same
guy same guy yeah with Pete and Taryn
yeah or Taryn and Pete depending on how
good your lawyer Samesies is nice
Samesies Samesies yeah the same as these
podcasts yeah and we call our fans
um Samos Samos John Samos Johnson
out there
ah and we just because I mean like we
have strikingly similar
uh pasts and I'm a little bit older than
you right I mean I'm 44 you're yeah you
were a senior I was a freshman
but still same Xperia yeah so yeah same
points of reference but same things that
that we were taken by that's right we're
inspired by on and continue to enjoy uh
last thing I'll say is the never-ending
story I put it on I think I was stoned
and it's just the stone eater eating
Stone and I'm like what the [__] is it
in my memory it opens with the longest
most Meandering like this was we were
all on LSD when we made this movie it's
not a good movie you remember Falcor and
the guys with the laser eyes of course
yes apparently that's like two hours
deep because there's a lot of guys with
the laser eyes are also like topless
women's statues that made me feel like I
I did yeah I shouldn't look anywhere at
these statues I'll throw in the woman
the shitsu that uh Jim Carrey saves and
the woman with the big whistles
on the ledge and he grabs the boobies
yeah comedy boobs yes the only boobs I
knew right and they were yes for a long
time deeply to this day I'll still be
like oh
it's it's so [__] weird yeah yeah
it's like that it's like
well you said airplane earlier airplane
Revenge of the Nerds which is just uh
doesn't age well but yeah airplane when
the boobs go by yeah anyway all right
Samesies all right soon to whomever you
get your podcasts on samsies who will
always close by saying we're the same
Z's but on this one we say keep it
crispy I just point because it's written
over your shoulder would you say keep it
crispy and you don't have to say it as
Brad Pitt were you sure
folks
keep it crispy
it's [__]
now do one is you okay
keep it crispy it was just
it was just everything
it was just Christmas thank you so much
[Music]
thank you